GOOD EVENING EVERYBODY IN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM FRAZIER
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
BEFORE WE GET STARTED WE NEED TO
TAKE CARE OF A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
MATTERS.
I CAN'T THINK SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC ENOUGH FOR ALLOWING US
TO USE ITS INNOVATION CENTER FOR
TONIGHT'S HEARING.
I'D LIKE TO ASK US STV'S GEN
PALUMBO.
EXAM A FEW WORDS ABOUT THIS
VENUE CHEN.
I'M CHEN I WORK HERE THE ENERGY
INNOVATION CENTER -- BEFORE I
GET STARTED I'M GOING TO
INTRODUCE CARLOTTA HUGH IS
OFFERING SPANISH TRANSLATIONS
FOR TONIGHT FOR ANYONE WHO NEEDS
IT. ONE IS THAT IT'S LIKE I'M
NOT THE CO ONE AND HIT THE ENTER
BUTTON ON YOUR PHONE TO WILL TO
LIVE AS HE DID IT I THE PHONE US
AND I'M A SECOND FAMILIES GET US
AND IN MOST OF WITH.
THAT IS.
WHO WE ARE THE ENERGY INNOVATION
CENTER WE ARE CONNECTED WITH SB
JEANNIE BECAUSE WE ADMINISTER AT
THE WORK FORCE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING PROGRAMS? FOR ALL OF
THEIR ENERGY EFFICIENCY OF
PORTFOLIO.
ARE WE ARE A LEAD PLATINUM
CERTIFIED BUILDING ACTUALLY JUST
GOT THAT OCCASION LAST MONTH FOR
THE SECOND TIME -- JUST A COUPLE
THINGS ABOUT.
THE BUILDING AND KIND OF SAFE
TODAY SO IF THERE IS AN
EMERGENCY AND WE NEED TO
EVACUATE THIS ROOM.
WE'RE GONNA GO OUT THE DOORS AND
WE WILL GATHER ON THE SIDEWALK
THAT IN FRONT OF A CRACKLING
FROM THE THING.
IF WE CAN'T GET OUT FRONT FOR
SOME REASON WILL USE OUR BACK
EXIT WHICH IS DOWN THE HALL.
PAST OUR REST -- WE LIKE TO STIR
EVERY MEETING HERE BY
DESIGNATING PEOPLE YOU.
DIAL 911- R. E. D. MACHINE AND
ADMINISTER CPR IN CASE THERE'S A
MEDICAL SINCE HE IN THE ROOM
WE'VE ALREADY DONE THOSE
DESIGNATIONS AND JUST GET ASK
THOSE FOLKS TO RAISE THEIR HANDS.
SO DIALING NINE ONE IS PAMELA.
IS EMMA.
ROOM.
SHE MAY BE.
DOING SCIENCE UP TURTLES IT
GRABBING R. E. D. THERE'S
CHARLES [INAUDIBLE]
AND AND EDWARD IS DOING CPR AND
EDWARD IS IN THE BACK THERE.
OKAY SO THAT'S ALL I HAVE -- I
WILL LET YOU GET STARTED AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE YOU THINK
YOU.
LOOKS LIKE WE'RE GOOD TO GO.
SO THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR COMING
OUT TO THE PARTICIPANTS HEARING
OF THE ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE
ON INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
I AM VERY GRATEFUL FOR THIS
[INAUDIBLE]
WONDERFUL TURNOUT.
IT TAKES A LOT OF EFFORT PUT ON
THESE HEARINGS SO IT'S
SATISFYING TO SEE SO MANY OF YOU
HERE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
EFFORT.
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS SHIRLEY WEBER --
SINCE ON SELECT COMMITTEE FOR
BEING HERE TONIGHT AND ALSO ON
THE WAY WHO JUST LANDED I'M.
MADE WHERE ASSEMBLYMEMBER TASHA
BORDER OR BAD.
SENATE PRESIDENT PRO TEM TEN
TWENTY ACTION STAFF FOR BEING
HERE.
IS SHE HERE IN THE AUDIENCE.
I'LL BE ON THE WAY -- ISN'T IF
YOU'RE HERE.
OKAY WELL -- KNOWLEDGES MANY
GETS HERE.
I ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
THANK STAFF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MARIE WALDRON.
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE QUE BEING
HERE TOM STINSON.
THANK YOU TOM FOR BEING HERE.
AND A SPECIAL THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE ON THE GROUND HERE IN
SAN DIEGO WHO WORK SO HARD TO
PUT THIS HEARING TOGETHER AND I
I REALLY DO APPRECIATE IT.
THIS COMMITTEE IS CONDUCTING AN
ONLINE SURVEY ABOUT THE REGIONAL
CENTERS.
AND YOU CAN FIND A LINK TO THE
SURVEY ON THE SELECT COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE OR ON MY LEGISLATIVE
WEBSITE.
A LINK CAN BE FOUND ON THE
BOTTOM OF YOUR AGENDA.
I ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO COMPLETE
THE SURVEY WITH YOUR EMPLOYER WE
WILL LEARN.
MORE ABOUT YOUR NEEDS ALSO.
THIS HEARING IS BEING LIVE
STREAMED TO THE SELECT
COMMITTEES PAGE ON THE STATE
ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE AND TO MY
LEGISLATIVE FACEBOOK PAGE YOU
CAN ALSO LIKE ME ON FACEBOOK
[INAUDIBLE]
YES A YES SIR HE SAID OR IN
PERSON.
VIDEO OF THE ENTIRE HEARING WILL
BE ARCHIVED A LINK TO THE SELECT
COMMITTEES PAGE.
WITH CLOSED CAPTIONS CAPSULES.
ALSO.
VIDEO OF THE MOST OF OUR VIDEO
OF MOST OF OUR PREVIOUS HEARINGS
ARE ARCHIVED AT SUBCOMMITTEE
PAGE.
AS WELL AS FUTURE HEARINGS WILL
ALSO BE.
BEFORE WE GET STARTED LIKE TO
ASK MY COLLEAGUES TO SAY A FEW
WORDS ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER.
THANK YOU AND GOOD EVENING.
THE NAME IT'S GOOD TO BE HOME
OUT SO I I DON'T FEEL LIKE A
GRIEVING SPECIAL BY BEING HERE
BECAUSE THIS ENABLES MY HOME.
BUT I'M JUST GRATEFUL FOR THE
NUMBER YOU JOIN US THIS EVENING
THIS IS REALLY A GREAT TURN OUT
I KNOW SOMEONE THOUGHT COULD BE
IT COULD BE LARGER BUT WE'VE
DONE ENOUGH OF THESE HEARINGS
LIKE THIS AS WELL AS OTHER
SELECT HEARINGS AND SOMETIMES
IT'S DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE. TO TO
GET TO PLACES BECAUSE OF THE THE
TIME FRAME MINUTES RIGHT AFTER
WORK IN BEFORE FAMILY AND DINNER
AND A HOST OF OTHER THINGS SO
THE FACT THAT YOU'RE HERE.
IT MAKES US FEEL VERY GLAD THAT
THE HAPPEN HERE OF THIS HEARING
IS TIMELY OBVIOUSLY -- WE OF
MISTER PHRASES AND MANY OF THESE
UP AND DOWN THE STATE I WANT TO
THANK HIM HE IS. ONE OF YOUR
STRONGEST ADVOCATES ARE IN THE
IN THE CAPITAL AND NOT JUST IN
THESE HEARINGS.
HE IS YOUR ADVOCATE IN PRIVATE
WHEN WE'RE IN MEETINGS AND
HAVING CONVERSATIONS AND HE
ALWAYS HAS OF THIS COMMUNITY ON
HIS MIND IT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT YOU'RE ALWAYS INCLUDED IN
THE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES AND BUDGET AND YOU
NAME IT AND SO IS COSTLY
FIGHTING FOR THIS COMMUNITY AND
I REALLY APPRECIATED SO.
WHEN HE ASKED ME TO SERVE ON HIS
SELECT COMMITTEE I WAS ON IT
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT HE IS EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT CARING CHEER AND
IT'S NOT JUST SOME?
PUBLICITY STUFF THAT SOMETIMES
FOLKS JUMP ON SOMETHING THAT
SEEMS TO BE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND GET SOME PUBLICITY
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE.
HIM AND AND FOR HIM COMING TO
SAN DIEGO -- AND TO COME IN TO
BE A PART OF IT -- AS A AS YOU
KNOW THIS IS A TIME HEARING
BECAUSE SOME OF YOU WATCH AND
AND FOLLOW AS CLOSELY IN TERMS
OF WHAT HAS HAPPENED WITH THE
BUDGET.
AND WHILE WE HAVE NOT GOTTEN TO
WHERE WE WANT TO BE THIS YEAR WE
GOT FURTHER THAN WE'VE BEEN.
AND WE'RE PLEASED ABOUT THAT AND
AND AND AND YOU PROBABLY HAVE
HEARD FOLKS ON THE FLOOR SAYING
OKAY DONE THIS BUT WE PROMISE TO
DO MORE AND WE'RE GOING TO DO
MORE AND SO WE'RE OPTIMISTIC
THAT.
OF FINALLY WE ARE FUNDING A
GETTING MORE FUNDING INTO AREAS
THAT WE KNOW NEEDS TO BE THERE
IN TERMS OF THE RISK OF MAKING
SURE THAT THE SERVICES.
AT OUR NEEDED THAT THAT THEY
THEY'RE THAT THIS FISCAL
SPONSORED BUILDING FOR ON OUR
PART MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE DOING
THAT -- WE ARE EXCITED ABOUT
WHAT THE FUTURE HOLDS FOR FOR
ALL OF THIS WORK THAT WE KNOW WE
HAVE TO DO.
AND I JUST APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE AND THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
FOR ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
DETRIMENTS OF BEING AT HOME.
IS THAT EVERYBODY KNOWS YOUR
HOME.
AND ADDED RESULT THEIR MEETINGS
AND I'M SUPPOSED TO BE ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF TOWN AT SEVEN AT
SEVEN THIRTY SO IF YOU SEE ME
SNEAK OUT IS NOT BECAUSE OF
SOMETHING YOU SAY IT.
I'M NOT SENSITIVE LIKE THAT --
BUT IT IS BECAUSE MY STAFF WHO'S
HERE DENISE GREEN IS HERE WITH
ME ARE -- HAS TO GET ME TO
HILLCREST IN TIME FOR MEETING
THIS EVENING BUT I DID WANT TO
COME LET YOU KNOW THAT YOU ARE
IN OUR HEARTS IN OUR MINDS.
AND WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT BEING
YOU KNOW ONE THING THE CHAIR OF
THE SELECT COMMITTEE MISTER
FRAZIER WHO IS DILIGENT AND HARD
WORKING ON BEHALF OF THIS
COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR
COMING OUT THIS EVENING.
THE MUTUAL ADMIRATION SOCIETY
BECAUSE I ADORE THIS WOMAN FOR
HER PASSION FOR HER ONLY
REGISTERED BUT FOR THE PEOPLE IN
THIS COMMUNITY AND WE WORKED
WELL TOGETHER SHE WAS THE BUDGET
BUDGET YEAR.
JUST ON HER REFERENCE ALONE SHE
WAS GETTING WELL THE AP ABA RE
REINSTATED SEVERAL YEARS AGO AND
THAT'S WAS AN ACCOMPLISHED THAT
WE NEVER KNEW THAT WE COULD GET
DONE WITH THE BUT IS WEBER DID
IT.
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT WHEN THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BORDER TO HORMUZ
SHOWS WILL WILL MAKE SURE THAT
SHE HAS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR AN
INTRODUCTION.
BUT AGAIN I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JIM FRAZIER I REPRESENT THE
ELEVENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
THE DELTA REGION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE I
CHAIR THIS COMMITTEE AND I'M
HELPING THE ID DO COMMUNITY IF
THE SUPPORT.
IS THERE IS FOR THE STATE OF AND
IT'S A PASSION FOR ME.
BUT THIS IS HEARINGS NOT ABOUT
ME.
WE'RE HERE TO LISTEN TO YOU NOW
WE CAN BETTER SUPPORT YOU. FOR
HER DISCUSS THE CHALLENGES FACED
BY FAMILIES WHO LIVE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
AND IT DEFECTS ALL OF US
REGARDLESS OF OUR BACKGROUND
WHERE WE LIVE OR HOW MUCH MONEY
WE MAKE.
R. IDG POPULATION CONTINUES TO
GROW WE MUST PROVIDE ESSENTIAL
SERVICES AND SUPPORT OR IT
FRIENDS.
NEIGHBORS AND AND OUR FAMILY
MEMBERS.
AT THE CAPITOL BECAUSE OF THE
DISTANCE WE DON'T HEAR FROM ALL
OF YOU AS MUCH AS WITH
[INAUDIBLE]
TWEET BUT AS A SPY COMMITTEE WE
DON'T HOLD HEARINGS ON PENDING
LEGISLATION.
BUT LEGISLATION COULD HAPPEN.
WITH YOUR INPUT AS IT OFTEN DOES.
WE LEARNED FROM PREVIOUS
HEARINGS THAT LISTEN TO STRIP IS
THE ARE THE MOST VALUABLE THING
WE CAN GET GOING TONIGHT.
WE HAVE SET ASIDE AMPLE TIME AT
THE IN FOR HEARING FROM PUBLIC
COMMENT HERE FOR YOU.
AND SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
YOUR INPUT -- BUT WE'RE HERE TO
GET STARTED.
WE HAVE A FANTASTIC LINE UP OF
PRESENTERS TONIGHT.
AND WE'LL BEGIN WITH A
PRESENTATION BY CARLOS FLORES
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE SAN
DIEGO REGIONAL CENTER.
OUR LOSS THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE THANK YOU MISTER.
THE MY CHECK IS THIS IT IS ON
NOW VERY GOOD -- GOOD EVENING
AGAIN.
MR WELCOME SAN DIEGO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER WELCOME
HOME GOOD TO SEE AGAIN -- THANK
YOU ALSO FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GIVE YOU INFORMATION ABOUT THE
SAN DIEGO REGIONAL CENTER AND
THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE SERVE
AND I REALLY APPRECIATED -- BY
THE WAY THIS YEAR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN MARCH OUR FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY -- WE WERE CREATED I
WILL OPEN THE DOORS ON FEBRUARY.
ONE NINETEEN SIXTY NINE ON
FEBRUARY ONE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WE HAD A REALLY COOL
GALA HERE IN SAN DIEGO THERE
WERE SIX HUNDRED THIRTY PEOPLE
THERE.
OF FROM ALL FOR ALL AREAS OF OUR
CONSTITUENCY ARE STAKEHOLDERS --
SENATOR OF THE SENATE PRESIDENT
PRO TEM TONI ATKINS CAME AND
STAYED FOR THE ENTIRE EVENT
LEAVE THAT.
CELEBRATIONS HAVE ALSO OCCURRED
AND OR OR PLAN FOR ALL OF OUR
FIVE LOCAL OFFICES WE'VE HAD ONE
IN OUR SAN DIEGO OFFICE
INTERNATIONAL CITY OFFICE.
AND EACH OFFICE OF WE HAVE
CLIENTS SERVICE PROVIDERS
FAMILIES ONLY ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
EACH OFFICE ALSO FOR TENS OR
LOOKING FOR TO THE REST OF THEM --
WE ALSO ARE USING THIS
COOPERATION AND COLLABORATION
THAT WE HAVE WITH OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS -- IT'S BEEN EXCELLENT
WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN AS A REGIONAL
CENTER FIRM BELIEVERS -- THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRANK THE
LANTERNA.
INTENDED THE REGIONAL CENTERS TO
BE COMMUNITY ENTITIES FOR THE
COMMUNITY AND BY THE COMMUNITY
AND THAT'S WHAT WE LIVE BY.
BY SERVICE TO PERSONS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
SPANS FORTY ONE YEARS I'VE BEEN
IN THE AND IN IN THE FIELD FORTY
ONE YEARS -- I'VE BEEN THE
DIRECTOR HERE SAN DIEGO FOR
TWELVE YEARS PRIOR I WAS THE
ASSOCIATE EXECUTIVE.
DIRECTOR FOR EIGHT YEARS -- I
WORK FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES
ADMINISTRATOR THE STAR PROGRAM
FOR INFANTS AND TODDLERS -- I
WAS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
RIVER WITH RIVER COAST REGIONAL
CENTER -- DIRECTOR OF THE AREA
FOR CAN NOW CALLED THE LOS
ANGELES REGIONAL OFFICE OF THE
CITY COUNCIL FOR DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES.
AND THAT WAS A PROGRAM MANAGER
AND SERVICE COORDINATOR FOR WEST
SIDE AND EASTERN LOS ANGELES
REGIONAL CENTERS.
SAN DIEGO REGIONAL CENTER WHERE
THE SECOND LARGEST IN THE SYSTEM
WE SERVE MORE THAN THIRTY
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE IN
SAN DIEGO AND IMPERIAL COUNTIES.
WE SERVE ABOUT TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND
PEOPLE IMPERIAL COUNTY.
NANCY BARGE IN THE IT DIRECTOR
OF THE ARMS OF DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES WE ARE THE FASTEST
GROWING REGIONAL CENTER IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY.
WE COMPLETE AN AVERAGE OF SIX
HUNDRED AND FORTY INTAKES PER
MONTH -- ARE.
GROWTH IS ABOUT TWO THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED CLIENTS PER YEAR IN
ADDITION -- ALLOCATION FOR
PURCHASE A SERVICEABLE OF
OPERATIONS AND OF EXCUSE FOR
PURCHASERS AND OPERATIONS IS
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
IN ORDER TO BE ACCESSIBLE TO THE
PEOPLE WE SERVE WE HAVE FIVE
OFFICE LOCATIONS -- WE HAVE
LOCATIONS IN CARLSBAD.
SANTEE NATIONAL CITY IMPERIAL IN
THEIR HEADQUARTERS IN PRETTY
MESA SAN DIEGO.
WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY SIX
HUNDRED INCREDIBLE STAFF.
WE ARE PLANNING TO ADD
ADDITIONAL OFFICE SPACE BECAUSE
OF OUR GROW ON LOOK AT THE EAST
LAKE AREA CHULA VISTA AND
CARAMEL MOUNTAIN AREA OF NORTH
INLAND COUNTY.
IN THE PAST. THREE YEARS WE'VE
ADDED FORTY ADDITIONAL SERVICE
COORDINATORS TO OUR STAFF -- BUT
OF FOR MOST SERVICE COORDINATORS
THE AVERAGE CASE LOAD IS STILL.
EIGHTY EIGHT WE HAVE LOWER CASE
LOADS FOR EARLY START THINGS
LIKE THAT BEFORE THE AVERAGE
USEFUL FOR MOSES BUT EIGHTY
EIGHT WE WOULD NEED SIXTY
ADDITIONAL SERVICE GREATER
SKINNER IN ORDER. TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH GISELE RATIO
REQUIREMENTS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER THANK YOU
FOR YOUR REMARKS ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR RECENTLY -- AS REPORTED IN
THE WAS OF THE SOLANO COUNTY
DALY REPUBLIC.
INADEQUATE RACE CREED OF A
CHALLENGE AS YOU KNOW -- THE
CHALLENGE TO ATTRACT AND KEEP
QUALIFIED STAFF FOR SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
HERE'S ONE EXAMPLE OF THE
EFFECTIVE LOW RATES.
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT WERE
SERVING WITH EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING DANGEROUS BEHAVIORS
DANGERS SELF AND OTHERS IS
GROWING.
YOU OPTIONS ARE BEING CREATED
LIKE COMMUNITY CRISIS HOMES HAS
BEHAVIORAL.
PROBLEMS HOWEVER FINING PAIN
QUALIFIED STAFF FOR THOSE
OPTIONS IS BECOME EXCEEDINGLY
DIFFICULT FOR SERVICE PROVIDERS
BECAUSE OF THE RATES.
THE SAME IS TRUE FOR NEGOTIATED
RATE HOMES.
ADULT RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES FOR
PERSONAL SPECIAL HEALTH NEEDS.
IN HAS BEEN HEROES FOR HOMES AND
OTHERS THAT WE'RE DEVELOPING OF
FOR CLIENTS WHO WILL BE MOVING
FROM THE COMMUNITY A TO THE
COMMITTEE FROM DEVELOPMENT
CENTERS.
AS WE PLAN TO CLOSE ORDER DRILL
AND THE FOR EVERY DEVELOPMENT
CENTERS.
WE HAVE REALLY GOOD
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE TWELVE
LOCAL SENATORS AND SO MANY
MEMBERS IN OUR AREA WE
APPRECIATE THEM A LOT AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH
THEM -- AS WE ADVOCATE -- FOR
INCREASED RATES FOR SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
I'D LIKE TO SHARE THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS AND STAFF BUT THE
ISSUE OF DISPARITY FOR FIRST
SERVICE.
IN THEIR MATERIALS ADVOCATES
CORRECTLY STATE THAT THE PER
CAPITA ANNUAL EXPENDITURES FOR
LEFT THE HOUSE TO THE FAR LEFT
YOU KNOW CLIENTS -- OR SEVEN
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
DOLLARS AND THE PER CAPITA FOR
WHITE CLIENTS OR SIXTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY
THIS IS A COMPARISON FOR CLIENTS
OF ALL AGES.
AND IT'S ONLY A PART OF THE
STORY.
WHEN THE DATA ARE SEPARATE INTO
THREE AGE GROUPINGS WE FIND THE
REST OF THE STORY?
SAN DIEGO REGIONAL CENTER FOR
EXAMPLE SPENDS MORE.
ON LATINO INFANTS AND TODDLERS
THEIR OWN WHITE INTERESTS OF
DOLLARS AGES BIRTH.
UP TO THREE YEARS. FOR LATINO
CLIENTS INSTANCES DOLLARS
EXPENDITURES ARE FIVE THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY AND FOR
WHITE INFANTS AND TODDLERS ARE.
FOUR THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
THIRTY ONE BUT SHOULD FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUNG ADULTS AGES
THREE TO TWENTY ONE YEARS OF AGE.
EXPENDITURES FOR LESBIANS ARE
THREE THOUSAND SIXTY DOLLARS AND
FOR WHITES THEY ARE FOUR
THOUSAND SEVEN OR NINETY NINE
DOLLARS SO THERE'S A DIFFERENCE.
THE DIFFERENCES FOR DAHLE
CLIENTS ARE THE MOST PRONOUNCED
1-700-040-0514 LESS YOU KNOW
CLIENTS. 270-009-0040 DOLLARS
FOR WHITE PLAINS.
THERE ARE MANY REASONS WHY THE
NUMBER OF DOLLARS AUTHORIZED
EXPENDED CAN BE DIFFERENT AMONG
THE VARIOUS ETHNIC AND RACIAL
GROUPS.
IS MOST LIKELY THAT THE
DIFFERENCES.
AMONG THE ETHNIC AND RACIAL
GROUPS PRIMARILY REFLECT
SUCH AS SOME CULTURES ARE LESS
LIKELY TO CHOOSE A RESIDENTIAL
PLACEMENT OPTION.
RESIDENTIAL PLACEMENT IS OUR
MOST COSTLY SERVICE AND THERE
ARE ABOUT THREE AND A HALF MORE
WHY CLIENTS IN RESIDENTS
PLACEMENT BAM BUT YOU KNOW
POINTS.
SAN DIEGO REGIONAL CENTER SPENDS
ALMOST SIX HUNDRED MILLION MORE.
A RESIDENTIAL PLACE FOR FOR WHY
CLIENTS THAN FOR LIFE YOU KNOW
POINTS.
WHEN THE RESIDENTS PLACEMENT
VARIABLES REMOVED?
MOST OF THE DISPARITY DISAPPEARS.
THE PER CAPITA EXPENDITURES ARE
ABOUT A NOW ABOUT NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR LIKE YOU KNOW POINTS
IN ABOUT TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR LIKE.
THE GOAL OF THE SAN DIEGO
REGIONAL CENTERS HAVE A
CULTURALLY INFORMED INSENSITIVE
DELIVERY SYSTEM THAT ENSURES ALL
CLIENTS IN BROWN'S RECEIVE
EXCEPT EXEMPLARY CUSTOMER
SERVICE.
AND THE SERVICES THEY NEED.
RATHER THAN THE GOAL OF EACH
ETHNIC AND RACIAL GROUP HAVING
THE SAME PURCHASE A SERVICE
PROFILE.
WE STRIVE TO SET RELEVANT
OUTCOME MEASURES SUCH AS
CUSTOMER SERVICE.
OF REGIONAL CENTER STAFF
ACCESSIBILITY [INAUDIBLE]
TIMELINESS RESPECTFUL MISS
PROFESSIONALISM SENSITIVITY TO
RACE AND ETHNICITY PASSAGE TO
LISTEN AND UNDERSTAND AND BE A
HELPFUL AND KNOWLEDGEABLE
PARTNER. TWO YEARS AGO.
WE EMBARKED ON A CUSTOMER
SERVICE CAMPAIGN.
ALL STAFF ARE TRAINED BY
PROFESSIONAL CONSULTANT PROVIDE
EXCELLENT EXTERNAL AND INTERNAL
CUSTOMER SERVICE.
IN ORDER TO MEASURE THE OUTCOMES
OF THE CAMPAIGN WE REDESIGN OUR
CLIENT AND FAMILY SATISFACTION.
SURVEY NOW HAS A FOCUS ON NINE
INDIVIDUAL CUSTOMER SERVICE
DIMENSIONS AND ONE OVERALL
SATISFACTION SCORE. FIVE
THOUSAND RANDOMLY SELECTED
SERVICE WERE MAILED TO CLIENTS
AND FAMILIES AND EIGHT HUNDRED
FIFTY WERE RETURN WHICH IS A
GOOD NUMBER.
RESPONDENTS WERE ASKED TO
IDENTIFY THEIR ETHNICITY THEY
IDENTIFIES WHITE.
ASIAN AFRICAN AMERICAN OR BLACK.
FILIPINO ENOUGH YOU KNOW.
THE RAVENS ACROSS ALL ETHNIC AND
RACIAL GROUPS WERE CONSISTENTLY
HIGH AVERAGING FOUR POINT.
FIVE ON A FIVE POINT RATING
SCALE.
ALL RESPONDENTS RIVER
REPRESENTING VARIOUS ETHNIC AND
RACIAL GROUPS REPORTED BEING
TREATED BY REGIONAL CENTER STAFF
RESPECTFULLY IN EARLY.
CELL CHANGE OF SUBJECT THE SAN
DIEGO REGIONAL CENTER IS A
LEADER IN CREATING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR PERSONS WILL DEVELOP
RULES REALLY SIMPLE SAN DIEGO
AND IMPERIAL COUNTIES.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
COLLABORATION WITH A FOUNDATION
FOR DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
I HELPED TO CREATE THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HOUSING COLLABORATIVE.
THE MISSION OF THE HOUSING
COLLABORATIVE IS TO LOCATE
INCREASE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPTIONS FOR REGIONAL CENTER
CLIENTS.
SHORTLY AFTER THE CREATION OF
HEALTH AND COLLABORATIVE WE WERE
FORTUNATE STREAMING FORTUNATE TO
DEVELOP A RELATIONSHIP AND A
PARTNERSHIP WITH CHELSEA
INVESTMENT CORPORATION.
CHELSEA THE LARGEST DEVELOPER OF
OR WILL HOUSING IN STAND YOU AND
IMPERIAL COUNTIES.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE HOUSING
COLLABORATIVE THE FOUNDATION
CHELSEA. TWO HUNDRED AND THREE
CLIENTS HAVE MOVED SO FOR
AFFORDABLE APARTMENT UNITS.
TWO HUNDRED THREE YOUR
PARTNERSHIP WE HAVE BILL FIVE
PROJECTS WITH SEVENTY SIX AND A
SIZE FOR PERSONS WITH THE ROLE
MODELS.
WE HAVE TO ADDITIONAL PROJECTS
UNDER CONSTRUCTION ONE IN SANDY
ONE IN REAL WITH TWENTY SEVEN
TOTAL SET ASIDE FOR CLIENTS.
ALSO WE'RE PLANNING.
IN THE PLANNING STAGES AND OR
SECURING FUNDING FOR THREE LARGE
PROJECTS ONE OF THE RIGHT DOWN
THE STREET FROM HERE.
WITH A HUNDRED FIFTEEN SAID
INSIGHTS [INAUDIBLE]
HELLO.
FUNDING FOR THESE PROJECTS
INCLUDE SEVEN FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE FOUNDATION FOR
THE REALM WILL STILL THESE AND
ONE MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT DEVELOP OFFICERS.
OUR FORMAL HAS NEVER SEVEN LIFE
CHANGING FOR PEOPLE WE SERVE.
FOR EXAMPLE YOUNG MAN.
WHO USES A WHEELCHAIR WAS
PROBABLY GIVEN TOUR OF HIS
FORMAL HOUSING UNITS?
WHEN HE REACHED THE BATHROOM OF
THE ROLE IN SHOWER HE BEGAN TO
CRY?
IT WAS NO LONGER NECESSARY TO
LIFT HIM INTO A TUB SHOWER. FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN HIS LIFE HE
CAN SHALL WE WILL PRIVACY REALLY
COOL.
A SINGLE MOTHER WITH TWO YOUNG
CHILDREN WAS LIVING IN A GARAGE
WITH A DIRT FLOOR.
OUR YOUNGEST CHILD HAS A
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY.
FAMILY WAS SELECTED TO MOVE INTO
A BRAND NEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING
APARTMENT.
THE MOTHER WAS **** IF YOU WORDS
DURING THE OPENING CEREMONIES
FOR THE APARTMENT COMPLEX.
SHE CHOSE OUR OLDEST DAUGHTER AS
YOUR INTERPRETER.
DURING HIS SPEECH BOTH THE
MOTHER AND DAUGHTER WERE
OVERCOME BY EMOTION AND THE
COULDN'T CONTINUE.
LATER I WAS THE FAMILY WAS
REALLY PROUD TO WELCOME ME INTO
THE READING AND WRITING HOLE.
WERE WONDERFUL EXPERIENCE.
THESE ARE TWO EXAMPLES OF THE
INCREDIBLE VALUE OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR THE PEOPLE WE SERVE.
OR JEFF BRIDGES SAN DIEGO
REGIONAL CENTERS PROUD TO BE
RECOGNIZED AS A HOUSING HERO FOR
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN BY THE
LAST MAN HOUSING COALITION.
ALLIANCE EXCUSE ME.
HOUSING LINES.
SEND YOU THE REASON CENTERS ALSO
RECOGNIZE ACROSS THE STATE. FOR
THE PROGRAM SERVICES WE'VE
CREATED FOR PERSONS WITH
DEVELOPMENTS ABILITIES AND
SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS.
AS WELL AS FOR OUR CLIENTS
ACCUSED OF COMMITTING -- FELONY
CRIMES -- AND IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WE HAVE STAFF WITH EXPERTISE IN
FORENSICS LOCATED ALL FIVE OF
OUR OFFICES.
WE ALSO PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE
MUSICIANS TO PROVIDE DIRECT
SERVICES.
WITH -- PUBLIC DEFENDERS OFFICES
WITH THEIR FEATURES DISTRICT --
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OFFICES AND
WITH THE SUPERIOR COURT JUDGES
BOTH INVISTA AND DOWNTOWN SAN
DIEGO.
REGIONAL CENTERS THERE IS A
RECENT RECIPIENT OF GRANT WE'RE
EXCITED ABOUT THE PILOT A
NATIONALLY CLAIM PROGRAM FOR
PERSONS WITH THE PROBLEMS
RELEASED IN CRISIS IT'S CALLED
START AS T. A. R. T..
LOOK FOR TO LEARNING FROM
NATIONAL EXPERTS TO BETTER SERVE
PEOPLE IN CRISIS.
IN ADDITION WE HAVE EXEMPLARY
SERVICE FOR CLIENTS WERE VICTIMS
OF CRIMES.
AND FOR THOSE OF SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
MY STAFF AND I AM SURE -- MODELS
THROUGHOUT THE CITY AND SEVERAL
REGIONAL CENTERS HAVE REPLICATED
THE SERVICES IN THEIR AREAS.
SAN DIEGO REGIONAL CENTER
RECOGNIZES THE VALUE OF OUR
SERVICE PROVIDER COMMUNITY.
AND OUR SHARED MISSIONS TO
CIRCUSES WILL DEVELOP RULES BILL
THESE.
WE FORGE STRONG RELATIONSHIPS
AND PARTNERSHIPS WITH SERVICE
PROVIDERS WE HAVE A JOINT
COMMITMENT TO IMPROVE THE
SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM IN OUR
AREA.
ALONG WITH CLIENTS AND FAMILIES
FOR EXAMPLE OR VISITS WITH
LEGISLATORS ALWAYS INCLUDE
SERVICE PROVIDERS.
REGIONAL CENTER AND REGIONAL
CENTER ANSWERING YOUR STAFF AND
A JOINT TRAININGS ON IMPORTANT
ISSUES ALL THE TIME SUCH AS THE
HOME TO ME BASED SERVICES WAIVER
NEW RULES [INAUDIBLE]
REGIONAL CENTER.
IS A LONG STANDING SUPPORTER OF
THE LOCAL.
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
PROVIDER NETWORK.
AND THE OTHER ANNUAL CONFERENCE
CALL LEADING THE CHARGE.
BENDER BY THREE COMMITTEE OF A
BOARD OF DIRECTORS IS EXTREMELY
ACTIVE LINES ALWAYS PLAYING A
ROLE IN PROVIDING VICE FOR THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS AND FOR
REGIONAL CENTER STAFF.
OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH SERVICE
PROVIDERS IS BUILT ON MUTUAL
RESPECT.
RATHER THAN BLAME WE SEEK
SOLUTIONS DURING TIMES OF
DISAGREEMENTS.
THERE ARE THOSE [INAUDIBLE]
CLOSING.
SAN DIEGO RESULTS CENTER HAS AN
EXCELLENT REPUTATION LOCALLY AND
ACROSS THE STATE.
THE STATE BEFORE WE A STRONG
WE'RE STRONG BELIEVERS THAT WE
WERE CREATED. FOR THE COMMUNITY.
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS AND I
HAVE AN OUTSTANDING RELATIONSHIP
WORK WELL TOGETHER TO ADMINISTER
THE REGIONAL CENTER.
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF MY
STAFF AND I HAVE WORKED HARD TO
CREATE AN ORGANIZATION BATES.
AND CULTURE.
BASED ON COLLABORATION
PARTNERSHIPS RESPECT
[INAUDIBLE]
TRANSPARENCY TRUST.
WE UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE AND
VALUE OVER COMMITTEE PART.
SUCH A SERVICE PROVIDERS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS COUNTY AGENCIES
UNIVERSITIES HOSPITALS
LEGISLATORS AND MANY MANY OTHERS.
THE MISSION OF THE SAN DIEGO
RICHARD CENTER IS AND I QUOTE.
TO SERVE AND EMPOWER PERSONS
WITH DEVELOPMENTS ELISE AND
THEIR FAMILIES TO ACHIEVE THEIR
GOALS WITH COMMUNITY PARTNERS.
EVERY WORD OUR MISSION HAS
PROFOUND.
REALLY APPRECIATE THE AFTERNOON
PROVIDE JUST ONE DAY AND SURE OF
ARC SHARE SOME OF OUR CONCERNS
CHALLENGES AND SUCCESSES.
MY THANKS TO THE SELECT
COMMITTEE LEGISLATURE'S IN
GENERAL -- FOR THE TIME
INTENTION YOU'RE GIVEN THE
SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM THAT
I'VE KNOWN AND LOVED FOR FORTY
ONE YEARS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE AND AND DOING YOUR
PRESENTATION.
AS YOU MENTION FORTY ONE YEARS
OF SERVICE TO THE SPECIAL NEEDS
COMMUNITY A WHEN DID YOU START
WHEN YOU'RE.
FIVE HEY THIS ORDER.
SO JUST WANTED TO AGAIN THANK
YOU IN AND IT KNOWLEDGE ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE'RE LOOKING.
AT IN THE LEGISLATURE IS. TO BE
MORE SUPPORTIVE OF THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND THE EMPLOYEES AND
THE CERTIFICATION OF THOSE
EMPLOYEES FOR THE MEDICALLY
FRAGILE THE BEHAVIORAL AND THE
DUAL DIAGNOSIS COMPONENT GOING.
UP AS WE AS WE KNOW THAT'S
ADVANCING AND WITH THE ADVANCE
POPULATION.
I MEAN TO YOUR INTAKES ARE.
STAGGERING -- SO.
DOCTOR WEBER NEIER OR HERE TO
LISTEN TO THE FOLKS.
AND UNDERSTAND THAT.
WE HAVE A LOT OF PROFESSIONALS
WHO WERE IN THE INDUSTRY WE DO
VERY GOOD WORK.
BUT THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND IS
WHERE WE'RE LACKING THE ABILITY
TO SERVE.
INDIVIDUALS THAT NEED THE
SERVICE.
AND SO.
I WILL LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU IN YOU TELLING ME WHAT
THAT TECH SCRAP THIS THAT
DISCREPANCY IS.
SO WE CAN WORK TOWARDS THAT --
STATUE THROUGH LEGISLATION TO
MAKE SURE THAT EACH INDIVIDUAL
HAS THAT ABILITY TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
AND THAT WE'RE NOT JUST
PROVIDING A SERVICE SO THAT YOU
CAN PUT THEM IN GROUP HOMES.
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND
ON THAT FOR YOU.
THANK YOU VERY.
WHAT WOULD YOU?
IN ONE THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE
GONNA CALL UP FROM NOW -- CINDY
MARTIN'S SUPER TEN OF SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THE NEW YEAR HERE [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
IS RENTAL -- ONLINE.
WELCOME THIS MORNING THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THIS IS A VERY PERSONAL AND A
LITTLE EMOTIONAL FOR ME SAID
LIKE TO INTRODUCE YOU TO MY
BROTHER.
CHARLIE CALLING.
SO COULD YOU AND YOU ALONE
CHARLIE ALBERT CALLING JUNIOR.
AND YOUR OWN HANDSOME GENTLEMAN.
WITHOUT A DOUBT.
SHARON FRAZIER THANK YOU FOR
HAVING THIS HEARING WHEN I FIRST
HEARD ABOUT IT.
I HAVE -- LUNCH EVERY WEEKEND
WITH MY BROTHER AND MY MOTHER
FERN SIEGEL OVER THERE.
AND EVERY WEEKEND WE SPEND OUR
TIME TOGETHER.
AND WHEN I FIRST HEARD ABOUT THE
HEARING I WANT TO JUST BRING
CHARLIE TO IT BECAUSE CHARLIE
LIKES ADVOCATE FROM SELF HE
COMES TO ADVOCACY EVENTS.
COUPLE YEARS AGO -- MARTY BLOCK
HAD WON I WENT IN WAS ON A PANEL
AND I STARTED SPEAKING AND MY
BROTHER WAS IN THE AUDIENCE
NINETEEN EVEN THOUGH HE WAS
COMING HIS STAFF.
WAS TREMENDOUS HE'S BEEN A
CLIENT OF REGIONAL CENTER FOR
MANY YEARS STAFF HAD BROUGHT HIM
AND I SAW HOW HE LEARNED HOW TO
ADVOCATE.
AND SO WHEN I FOUND OUT ABOUT
THIS IS THE CHARLIE LET'S GO
THEN SOMEHOW YOU ALL HEARD I WAS
COMING YOU PUT ME ON THE PANEL
SO.
THEY FIRST CAME OUT I'M HERE
FIRST AS A SISTER A FAMILY
MEMBER BUT I AM THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU AND
DOCTOR WEBER.
AND THE WORK THAT YOU ALL DO AND
THE OTHER ELECTED OFFICIALS THAT
ARE COMMITTED TO SUPPORTING ARE
YOU. FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HEARD AFTERNOON I'M PROUD TO AS
I SAID IN ADDITION TO MY BROTHER
CHARLIE CHARLIE CAN SPEAK FOR
HIMSELF.
ON THESE CRITICAL ISSUES AND HE
CAN HELP ADVOCATE FOR THE MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS SERVE DAILY BY THE SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
I'M BEGINNING MY SEVENTH YEAR
SUPERINTENDENT OF SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE WORK OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND WE BELIEVE
THE NEED FOR FULL AND FAIR
FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY BASED
PROVIDERS AS A MATTER.
OF URGENT IMPORTANCE SOME ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SAN DIEGO YOU
KNOW STUDENTS AGE OUT OF OUR
SCHOOLS EVERY YEAR AND BECOME
ELIGIBLE FOR CARE AT THE
REGIONAL CENTERS.
AT THE REGIONAL CENTER HOWEVER
WE ACTUALLY BEGIN WORKING.
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION OUR
STUDENTS BEFORE THAT DATE AND
BEFORE STUDENTS LEAVE OUR CARE.
DIFFICULTY THROUGH A TRACE
PROGRAM WE WORK WITH REGIONAL
CENTERS DURING THE LAST YEAR A
STUDENT IS IN OUR PROGRAM TO
FACILITATE A GRADUAL RELEASE TO
THE ADULT AGENCIES.
IN OUR COMMUNITY.
WE ALSO WORK THE REGIONAL CENTER
TO PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR THE
FAMILIES WE SERVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY FIND THE RIGHT FIT IN
MOVING TO AN ADULT AGENCY.
QUICK FUNDING FOR THE REGIONAL
CENTER IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
JUST BECAUSE A LACK OF FUNDING.
RESULTS AND OUR STUDENTS BEING
PLACED WEIGHTLESS AT ADULT
AGENTS AND THAT LIMITS THE
OPTIONS OUR STUDENTS AND FOR
THEIR FAMILIES AS A TRANSITION.
AS A LEADER OF A LARGE
ORGANIZATION I'M WELL AWARE
ESPECIALLY AT THIS TIME OF YEAR
OF THE INTENSE BUDGETARY
PRESSURES THAT WE ALL FACE.
OVER SAN DIEGO UNIFIED STRONGLY
BELIEVES AND I'M CONFIDENT YOU
ALL AGREE THAT FULL AND FAIR
FUNDING OF THE REGIONAL CENTERS.
IS AN ESSENTIAL PRIORITY FOR OUR
STATE.
AND I WANT TO ALSO INTRODUCE OUR
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION SERRA OUGHT.
IS HERE FOR PEOPLE STAND -- AND
SPECIFICALLY THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT ARE SUPPORTING OUR STUDENTS
AS THEY LEAVE SAN DIEGO UNIFIED
THE ADULT DAY PROGRAMS AND JOB
COACHING RECREATION SUPPORT
BEHAVIORAL SUPPORTS RESPITE CARE.
FUNDING THE LIVING PLACEMENTS
LEGAL SUPPORT FOR GUARDIANSHIP
THE THINGS THAT MY COLLEAGUE WAS
ABLE TO SAY SOME UP ABOUT VERY
SPECIFIC KAREN HOW IMPORTANT
THIS IS. FOR OUR STUDENTS AND
FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND AS A
FAMILY MEMBER WHO'S BEEN A
DIRECT RECIPIENTS AND OBSERVE
WHAT -- HAS HAPPENED FOR MY
FAMILY BECAUSE OF THE SUPPORT OF
REGIONAL CENTER FOR YEARS
CHARLIE WAS A STUDENT IN SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED.
TRACE PROGRAM WASN'T AROUND THEN
BUT CHARLIE WAS A STUDENT UNTIL
ADULT AGE AND THEN TRANSITION
AND HAS LIVED IN GROUP HOMES HAS
LIVED IN.
DISABILITIES -- ALWAYS A ONE I'M
SPRINGS CANYON SPRINGS FACILITY.
BECAUSE HE WAS.
FEDERAL CITY AND THAT AND NOW
HE'S BACK IN THE COMMUNITY AND
LIVING INDEPENDENTLY THANKS TO
THE SUPPORT OF REGIONAL CENTER
AND I WANNA SAY THANK YOU TO
STAFF WAS HERE.
XING IS HERE WHO'S A STAFF
MEMBER WHO IS WORKING WITH THEM
THIS EVENING.
YES I AM A TEAM OF SEVEN WHO
WORK WITH HIM TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
TO LIVE INDEPENDENTLY IN THE
COMMUNITY.
THANKS TO THE WORK OF AN
ORGANIZATION CALLED NETWORKS
WHICH THE CONTRACTS WITH.
REGIONAL CENTER AND WE COULD NOT
BE MORE HAPPY WITH THE SUPPORT
THAT HE'S GETTING BUT WE KNOW
THAT.
WE'VE SCHEME.
IN THE RATE STUDY THAT WAS
COMMISSION TWO YEARS AGO ON THE
REPORT THAT WAS RELEASED IN
MARCH IS THAT.
THIS -- THE COMMUNITY SYSTEM
SUPPORTS THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE THROUGH THE
REGIONAL CENTERS IN THE STATE
AND ITS UNDERFUNDED BY ABOUT 40%.
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION AND I
WORK WITH MY COLLEAGUES AND
ADVOCATES ALL THROUGHOUT THE
CITY TO BE ABLE TO COME TO YOU
TODAY TO SAY THAT WE WANT TO SEE
IT.
SO EVERYBODY HAS. TO THE SUPPORT
THAT THEY NEED TO BE SUCCESSFUL
IN THE COMMUNITY LIKE MY BROTHER
CHARLIE.
AND CHARGE OF ANYTHING YOU WANT
TO SAY THE ADVOCATE.
IN ORDER IS A LIVE HERE AND THE
KIDS.
ONLY ONE OF MILLION -- ME.
WITH THEIR MEMBERS.
ONLY HELP FORMER YEAR
[INAUDIBLE]
BROWN JUNIOR.
SHOULD YOU WISH [INAUDIBLE]
WELL -- NORMAN LARA AND USE
THEIR WILLS -- AS IS ALL YOUR
FRIENDS CHARLIE.
MEMBERS YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
NEWS SOON.
HE RUNS.
ON LONG RECALLS YOUR BERMAN.
TO MINIMUM ON THE ROAD.
SURE.
WHAT IS IT?
WITH.
ONLY.
NOW AND THEN ONE CUP OF MIDDLE
NAME THEIR FRIEND'S NAMES THEIR
BIRTHDAY -- WIENER I CAN TELL
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR THEM
OR ANYTHING ELSE FOR YOU -- THE
WHAT IS ADVOCACY.
YOU KNOW WHATEVER CONVENIENCE --
EVERY KID.
WELL THAT'S RIGHT ARE YOU A SELF
ADVOCATE YES THEY DO ARE
[INAUDIBLE]
CHARLIE ROCK.
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
COMING IN AND SHARING WITH US --
WHAT CAN WE DO IF YOU HAD IF YOU
HAD ONE WISH OF SOMETHING THAT
YOU REALLY THINK WOULD MAKE A
REAL DIFFERENCE FOR YOU?
AND ALL YOUR FRIENDS WHAT WOULD
THAT BE [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
AND THE AND THE AND THE MOTION
IS THE ONLY REALLY.
WELL ME.
WARMLY MORE VETERANS AND HOME
LIVING HERE ALONE. TWO YEARS --
IMMINENT -- HEROES REALLY LEARN.
THEM DURING.
NOW IT'S LIKE ABOUT HIS
GIRLFRIEND THAT HE'S GETTING
MARRIED TOO BUT HE DIED OUR
CHARLIE AND DUMPING WOMEN IS NOT
VERY POPULAR DOES HE RECENTLY
HAD WAS A SELF I THINK IT WAS
THE GOVERNMENT ISSUED CELLPHONE.
THAT'S BEEN HELPFUL BECAUSE I
THINK HE'S GETTING DIRECT ACCESS
TO THINGS ARE BEING SENT TO HIM
VIA TAX THEM IN TRYING TO TAX
SOME INTERESTING IS.
LEGALLY BLIND BUT HE CAN READ
CHARLIE READS AT A COLLEGE LEVEL
CAN UNDERSTAND IT ALL -- OR CALL
DURING A BOOK TOGETHER.
WELL MORE LEADERS ARE THE ONES
WHO ARE YOU.
OR CALL THE OTHER -- MONEY WILL
MOVE YEAH WE'RE READING SPELLING
BOOK TOGETHER BECAUSE CHARLIE'S
ONE OF HIS GIFTS AS HE CAN SPELL
ANY WORD IN THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE
YOU GIVEN MANY WORD AND HE CAN.
SPELL IT HE HAS THAT KIND OF I
KIND OF MEMORY BUT THE THAT
CELLPHONE WAS IMPORTANT -- SOME
THING RECENT THAT HAPPENED WAS
CHANGE WHERE HE NO LONGER HAVE
TO PAY FOR CERTAIN PERSONAL
PRODUCTS.
I THINK THAT WAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ -- HAD SPENCER BUT THAT
HELPED HIS REGULAR MONTHLY SO A
CERTAIN AMOUNT HAD TO GO TO THAT
TYPE OF PRODUCT AND IT DIDN'T
ANYMORE SO.
THE KINDS OF THINGS HE HAS IS
THE B. T. AS STAFF TAKE SOME
SHOPPING HE'S ABLE AGO.
INDEPENDENTLY TO DO THAT THEIR
IS THERE SOMETHING SPECIFIC YOU
WANT ADVOCATE FOR SHE SAID IF
YOU HAVE ONE WISH BESIDES
PERSONAL.
THANK YOU FOR GETTING MARRIED
WHAT DO YOU NEED FOR YOUR HOUSE
OR FOR YOUR LIVING TO HELP YOU
BE MORE SIX SOLDIERS.
THE JURORS.
BUT NOT COOLERS.
YEAH I WILL NOT COLLEGE OR RUN.
NO ONE MOVIE EVER.
WITH THE ROOM.
MOBILE USER THE LITTLE -- THERE
ARE NONE. ONE OF HIS BIG WISHES
SAID TO BECOME A BIOCHEMIST MY
SONS GRADUATED FROM COLLEGE AND
GETTING A MASTERS IN THAT AREA
AND SOME TYPE OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CLASSES IT'S GOING TO BE
LIKE YOU YOU WANT TO BE LIKE ME.
LET'S BE LIKE HIS NEPHEW YOU
WENT TO COLLEGE WHY CAN I GO TO
COLLEGE WHAT CAN I TAKE CLASSES
THERE SO IT'S BEEN A BIG GOAL
FOR HIM. TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
GET OVER TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND AND REGISTER AND
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS HAVE TO
NAVIGATE TO DO THAT SO ANYTHING
THAT YOU CAN DO TO HELP OUT OF
THE BIG.
DREAM OF AS THAT IS GONNA GOAL
OF MANY PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY
AND AND YOU KNOW WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO CREATE THAT CREATE THAT
PATH INSTEAD OF GOING TO LIFE
SKILLS WE CAN HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
FOR THE TO YOUR FOR YOUR
EXPERIENCE SO WE JUST.
NEED YOUR GUIDANCE BE ABLE TO DO
SO AND LOOK HOW WE CAN MAKE THAT
HAPPEN BECAUSE I I FIRMLY
BELIEVE.
THAT SHOULD BE AN OPTION FOR
EVERY INDIVIDUAL NO MATTER WHAT
THEIR CAPABILITIES.
WE'LL BE HAPPY AS A AS DISTRICT
WE HAVE.
DONE THAT BUT ALSO THROUGH THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT WE HAVE HELPED
OUR FINANCE PATHWAYS MAKING UP
WITH SOMEONE.
I APPRECIATE AND CHARLIE.
I WANT TO BE LIKE YOU.
HOW ARE YOU [INAUDIBLE]
LEROY.
NOW I KNOW A LITTLE NAY
[INAUDIBLE]
FRAZIER.
NOW YOU GOT THAT.
WE'LL BE TALKING OKAY I CAN HE'S
GONNA ASK YOU CAN BE BEST.
IF I'M GOING.
THANK YOU JOHN.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY THAT WE HAD
A OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WHO IS NOT ON A LATE FLIGHT?
WHO RUSHED OVER TO COME AND JOIN
US AND I CAN'T THANK HER ENOUGH
FOR BEER -- SOMEONE PLEASE.
TRADITIONS OF THE CROWN.
THANK YOU EVERYONE MY NAME'S
TASHA BOERNER HORVATH I
REPRESENT.
EIGHTY SEVENTY SIX INSIDIOUS
CARLSBAD OCEANSIDE AND THIS
STUFF.
AND CAMP PENDLETON IS HONORED TO
BE HERE -- YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN I
GOT MY START AS A PTA MOM SO WE
WORK A LOT WITH THE THE IDT
COMMUNITY AS A PTA MOM AND
THAT'S WHERE I COME FROM MY
DAUGHTER ALSO HAS SPECIAL NEEDS.
IT'S SESSION ARE TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE COMMUNITIES -- THAT REALLY
NEED -- THAT I KNOW PERSONALLY
WHO WHO NEED -- OUR GUIDANCE FOR
THE STATE IN OUR SUPPORT FROM
THE STATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARCHER FRAZIER FOR HAVING HERE
TODAY THANK YOU I APPRECIATE YOU.
WE GOT A SESSION TODAY AND WE
HAD A BUDGET TRAILER BILLS
COMING DOWN THE PATH AND WE HAD
MEETINGS AFTERWARDS AND AND
COMMITTEE IN.
AND FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS TO
COME HERE AFTER A FULL DAY AND
THEN ALSO INVESTING IN THIS IS --
EFFORT I CAN'T THINK BOTH OF YOU
ENOUGH FOR THAT PURPOSE.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THOSE WHO
PRETEND MARTIN FOR BEING HERE
YOU I MEAN LISTEN YOU'RE THE ONE
THAT MAKES THE THING WORK FOR
THE KIDS.
AND I LOVE YOUR PASSION AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU.
I APPRECIATE THAT -- SO WE HAVE
MORE PRESENTATIONS COMING UP AND
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU WERE
OF WHO ARE PRESENT -- PRESIDENT
TONIGHT.
OF FOR BEING HERE THIS EVENING.
I ASK YOU TO KEEP A
PRESENTATIONS TO A TIME ALLOTTED
ON THE JANIS SO WE CAN KEEP ON
SCHEDULE.
AND SO WE'RE GONNA BE MOVING ON
TO THE PROVIDERS MARK WILL BE --
THE SINGLE GUY WITH THE TIME.
AND WHEN YOU SEE IT IF YOU DON'T
HEED THE TIME.
AND I'LL CATCH OFF.
SO THAT WE CAN KEEP GONE.
SO ANYWAY I WANT TO BE ABLE TO
CALL -- AND WE'RE HER SHE FROM
HOME OF GUIDING HANDS.
WE'RE HERE.
THANK YOU COME ON UP.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
GOOD EVENING ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER AND FELLOW MEMBERS OF
THE SELECT COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES WE AS
PROVIDERS OUR FATE.
AS WELL AS MY PERSONAL STORY
STRUGGLES MY FAMILY AS FACING.
FIRST A BRIEF HISTORY OF GUIDING
HANDS SINCE OUR INCEPTION IN
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE I'M A GUIDING
THIS IS PROVIDED BENCHMARK
PROGRAM AND HOUSING FOR MEN
WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
HHH IS ONE OF THE LARGEST
PROVIDERS OF SUPPORTS AND SERVE
AS AN INDIGO COUNTING SERVING
MORE THAN THREE THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED INFANTS.
LESSONS IN ADULTS.
OVER THE YEARS HHS EXPANDED.
PROVIDE A CONTINUUM OF SERVICE
FOR ALL AGES.
FROM EARLY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT
SERVICING AND FIX AND TODDLERS.
RESIDENT SERVICES FOR CHILDREN
ADOLESCENTS AND ADULTS.
IN HOME RESPITE SERVING ALL AGES.
COMMUNITY LIVING PROGRAM
COUNSELING AND SUPPORT SERVICES
TRANSPORTATION RIGHTY OF QUALITY
OF LIFE PROGRAM.
LIKE OTHER ORGANIZATIONS WITH
OUR INDUSTRY WE'RE FACING A FUN
CRISIS.
AS RECALL BY EIGHTY X. TWO ONE
THE DEPARTMENT OF SERVICES
COMMISSION AND ASSOCIATES.
PLEASE ENTER RATE STUDY.
AND SO THE RAPE MODELS.
WHILE THEY'RE STILL SOME DEBATE
ON ELEMENTS OF THE RATE STUDY IT
DOES PROVIDE US BUT I SYSTEM.
WHAT WE CAN ALL AGREE ON AND
WHAT THE RATE STUDY DOES
HIGHLIGHT IS THAT THE SERVICE
PROVIDER DRASTICALLY UNDERFUNDED?
IT'S STUDY SHOWED THAT THE
INDUSTRY.
WE ARE 40% UNDER FIRE. ONE OF
PROGRAMS THAT H. H. PROVIDES IS
TRANSPORTATION.
WE PROVIDE.
SERVICES FOR THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
IN RITUALS DALY PROVIDING ACCESS
INTO THE COMMUNITY.
TRANSPORTATION IS THE GREAT
EQUALIZER ESPECIALLY IN SAN
DIEGO IT'S HARD TO GET ANY WORK
OUT TRANSPORTATION.
OUR SO WITHOUT WAS MUCH NEEDED
SERVICES WERE LIMITING THE
ABILITY OF PEOPLE TO BE PART OF
THEIR COMMUNITY.
I'M.
AT HOME OF GUIDING HAND OUR
TRANSPORTATION DEPARTMENT.
IS RUNNING FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH IN THE NEGATIVE.
NOW I'M NOT THE CFO OF THE
COMPANY BUT EVEN I CAN FIGURE
OUT THAT AT THAT RATE OF LOS
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
SUSTAIN THAT MUCH LONGER.
ANOTHER CRISIS WE ARE FACED THE
STAFFING CRISIS.
HOME OF GUIDING HANDS WITH WE
HAVE A 40% TURNOVER IN THE
DIRECT SERVICE PROVIDERS.
I'M CREATING A WORKFORCE CRISIS.
THIS CRISIS THREATENS THE HEALTH
SAFETY AND WELL BEING OF PEOPLE
WITH.
DISABILITIES ARE THE DIRECT
PRESS PROVIDERS WHO ARE TIRED
WITH WORKING LONG HOURS OR
MULTIPLE JOBS.
MUCH MORE LIKELY TO MAKE
MISTAKES.
HAVE A LOWER TOLERANCE FOR
STRESSFUL SITUATIONS.
WHEN THE SERVICE PROVIDERS DO
NOT KNOW THE PERSON FOR WHOM
THEY ARE PROVIDING SUPPORT?
THEY MAY NOT RECOGNIZE SIGNS AND
SYMPTOMS ILLNESS.
THE CONSISTENCY OF THE DIRECT
SERVICE TURN OVER AND THEY CAN
SEE RATE.
IMPACT INDEPENDENCE AND
OPPORTUNITIES EXPERIENCED BY THE
PEOPLE WE SUPPORT.
THE IMPACT OF THE WORK FORCE
CRISIS IS ALSO AND SIMPLE LIFE
AND WELL BEING OF THE FAMILY.
SO SHIFTING GEARS I'M ALSO A
FAMILY MEMBER -- SO LET ME TELL
YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT MY STORY.
SO MY DAUGHTER.
LIKE MOST YOUNG ADULTS SHE HAS A
PASSION FOR LIFE.
LOVES MUSIC ENJOYED MEETING NEW
PEOPLE AND DANCE.
SHORTLY AFTER HE WAS BORN SHE
WAS DIAGNOSED WITH WILLIAM. ONE
OF THE THINGS WHEN YOU MEET
JULIA SHE DEEP SEEDED LOVE
EVERYBODY WE CAN LEARN A LOT.
FROM HER.
WHEN SHE MEETS YOU YOU GUYS ARE
BEST FRIENDS FOR LIFE REMEMBER
FIVE YEARS LATER WHAT
CONVERSATION WAS THE FIRST TIME
WHAT YOU'RE WEARING?
EVERYTHING ABOUT IT.
BY.
YOUNG ADULTS HER PASSION IS TO
MOVE OUT ON HER OWN.
AND SHE STARTED THAT JOURNEY A
YEAR AND A HALF AGO.
SENSE SHE HAS HAD THREE DIRECT
SERVICE PROVIDERS.
SHE'S HAD.
ARE.
THREE SERVICE COORDINATORS FROM
THE CENTER. FOR DIRECT SERVICE
PROVIDERS CHANGED IN FOUR YEARS.
AS YOU HEARD ME TALK A LITTLE
BIT CAPTION AND HER LOVE FOR
PEOPLE.
YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW SHE TAKES AT
SO AT THIS POINT NOW YOU CAN.
SHE HASN'T BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
REACHING HER GOAL.
IN ADDITION SHE TO US ALL.
SO EVERY TIME SOMEONE LEAVES SHE
FEELS ARE LEAVING BECAUSE OF HER.
SO THE WHOLE PROCESS HAS TO
START OR WHERE SHE BUILDS TRUST
RELATIONSHIP.
I THAT TIME CHANGED -- STARTED
ALL OVER AGAIN -- SO SHE HASN'T
BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN HER MEETING
HER GOAL.
SO IN CLOSING.
AS A PROVIDER I'D ONCE AGAIN
THANK YOU GUYS FOR THE WORK
YOU'RE DOING -- YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND DEDICATION -- IS IMPRESSIVE
SO PLEASE KEEP IT UP.
OUR AS A FAMILY MEMBER I'D
ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY IN THE ROOM
KEEP PUSHING.
THE REAR END INCREASE WHILE SOME
AT SEARS X. EXCESS WAS A SUCCESS
WE WENT FROM. ZERO EIGHT POINT.
TWO THAT'S A SUCCESS WHILE WE
SHOULD CELEBRATE THAT WE KEEP
THE PRESSURE GOING.
KEEP PUSHING AND KEEPING US ALL.
THANK YOU.
WELL DEEP REACHING FROM THE
UNITED CEREBRAL PALSY AND THEN
ALSO A SAN DIEGO AND ALSO OR
CENTOS FROM MARK OF IMPERIAL
VALLEY.
WHICH BOTH COME UP AND THEN.
I GAVE YOU CAN START FIRST AND
THEN WE'LL HAVE OUR THANK YOU
BOTH GENTLEMEN FOR BEING HERE
THIS EVENING.
SORRY PLEASURE THANK YOU TO ALL
OF YOU UP THERE FOR THE THE
EFFORT YOU MADE IN TERMS OF
GETTING THE RECENT INCREASE. TO
GO THROUGH -- I'LL BEGIN BY
SAYING MY NAME IS DAVE COURAGE
AND THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. FOR
UNITED CEREBRAL PALSY I'VE BEEN
THERE FOR FORTY SIX YEARS LAST
TWENTY ONE AS THE EXACT I
STARTED WHEN I WAS IN HIGH
SCHOOL.
AND I'LL ALSO SAY I'LL.
BEGIN BY SAYING THE BEST THREE
IN HIS WORDS IN THE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE [INAUDIBLE]
SO [INAUDIBLE]
OUR AGAIN THANK YOU FOR WHAT
YOU'VE DONE I THINK IT'S AN AND
IT SENDS AN IMPORTANT MESSAGE
[INAUDIBLE]
AND I THINK IT'S TANTAMOUNT TO
FIRING FOR SHOP BASICALLY IN
TERMS OF REPAIRING THINGS AND
AND HELPING.
FAMILIES TO GET THEIR SERVICES
PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE THEM OF
WORKERS TO STAY EMPLOYED A LOT
OF DIFFERENT THINGS.
AT U. C. P. WERE MORE MORE
LANDED IN PROGRAMS AND
RESIDENTIAL AND SOME OF THOSE.
HAVE -- HAVE SEEN THE INCREASE
AND SOME HAVE NOT AND THERE'S A
TRANSITION GOING ON AS WELL.
HOW THAT MIGHT LOOK WITH THE NEW
AGE CBS REGULATIONS OR WHATEVER?
I WILL ONLY ADD THAT HAVE A
RANGE OF CONSUMER CHOICES.
HELPS TO REVIVE THE RICH QUALITY
OF LIFE IT'S IT'S IT'S MORE THAN
JUST IT'S IMPORTANT WHERE THEY
LIVE.
WE GET THAT.
BUT I THINK WHAT THEY'RE DOING
IN THEIR IN THEIR IN THEIR HOURS
TO DATE IN RICHER LIVES OR
EDUCATE IN THEIR WORK
POSSIBILITIES AND ALL THOSE.
I THINK ARE GOING TO BE VERY.
LONG WAY AND SO I THINK -- AS A
STATE AS A GROUP OF PEOPLE.
WE NEED MORE CARE IN TERMS OF
HOW WE'RE MAKING OUR CHOICES.
WHAT WE FIND IN WHAT WE DON'T
[INAUDIBLE]
AND AGAIN WE'RE HERE TO HELP IF
YOU NOT SURE ABOUT SOMETHING WE
CAN GIVE YOU SOME INSIGHT
ESTARÁ THINGS ARE GOING.
WE ALSO ARE LIKE A LOT OF OTHER
PROVIDERS IN THE ROOM I DON'T
WANT TO SPEAK FOR THEM TOTALLY
BUT IT'S IT'S VERY HARD TO KEEP
GOOD STAFF.
BASED ON WHAT THE WAGES ARE
LOOKING LIKE.
AND EVEN WITH THE BUMPS IN.
IN THE MINIMUM WAGE I THINK CAN
ALL AGREE THOSE ARE NOT LIVEABLE
WAGE LAWS ARE MINIMUM WAGE.
SO I THINK IT'S A MATTER OF
PROTECTING THAT AND ALONG WITH
THAT QUALITY PEOPLE ARE WORKING
THERE.
AND GOOD SERVICES ARE BEING PUT
FORTH SAFE SERVICES IMPORTANT
SERVICE SAYS.
I WON'T BE ON TRANSITIONING SOME
OF OURS TO NEW REGULATIONS
COMING UP AND I THINK IT'S IT'S
FOR GOAL TO STAY THE SAME ALL
THE TIME AND THAT'S NOT WHAT
WE'RE THERE FOR WE TRY TO BE
INNOVATIVE.
WE TRY TO PROVIDE GOOD SERVICES --
IT'LL TAKE TIME SO WE NEED TO BE
CAREFUL AGAIN AS WERE.
WERE DECIDING WHAT WE FIND WHAT
WE DON'T FUND BECAUSE THERE'S A
TRANSITION GOING ON AND IT COULD
CAUSE.
SOME COULD STORE STAFF.
BECAUSE CONSTRUED PROGRAMS.
YES I THINK AGAIN I WOULD ONLY
SAY LET'S SPEAKER -- CARLOS
FLORES MENTION OBVIOUSLY WHICH
WERE ALL AWARE OF THE PLAN --
ENACT.
OUR I REALLY DO THINK THAT'S
WHAT SEPARATES US FROM THE REST
OF THE NATION IN THE WORLD HAVE
ENTITLEMENTS NOBODY ELSE HAS I
THINK WE SHOULD BE.
FIERCELY PROUD OF THAT I THINK
IT IT SHOWS UP IN THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE NOT LONG WAITING LISTS
FOR SERVICES IN OUR STATE.
TALKING TO COUNTERPARTS PART OF
A NATIONAL ORGANIZATION THAT YOU
SEE P..
WHAT CLICK IN THE STATE'S IN
TEXAS AND ARIZONA THEY'RE
THEY'RE QUEUING UP WITH NOWHERE
TO GO AND I THINK CALIFORNIA IS
DOING A BETTER JOB WITH THAT?
AND THAT'S BECAUSE WE HAVE THIS.
TO HELP GUIDE US SO I THINK WE
WANT TO BE WE WILL BE VERY
PROTECTIVE OF IT AND WE SHOULD
BE VERY PROUD OF IT WE ARE
DIFFERENT THAN EVERYBODY ELSE.
SOME.
BUT I I AGAIN WE DO A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS AND I I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT.
CONSUMERS HAVE A CHOICE THE
THREE SELF DETERMINATION IF IT'S
NOT THAT WAY AT ANY RATE IT
NEEDS TO BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
SOMEBODY TO ENRICH THEIR LIVES.
THAT'S NOT IT IT'S MORE THAN
JUST BERMAN HONESTLY WHERE MY
WAKING UP.
IT'S LIKE WHAT IS ONE DAY NO.
AT UCP WE HAVE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT.
FOR EVERYTHING FROM -- STUDENTS
SUPPORTS.
GOING TO COLLEGE -- WE DO WORK
TRAINING AND PLACEMENT ASSISTIVE
TECHNOLOGY WHICH IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
I KNOW SOME OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
MENTION TRANSPORTATION THAT'S
WHY I STARTED IT YOU SEE HE I
WAS DRIVING THE VAN. TO AND FROM
COLLEGE CLASSES -- IN THE
MORNING IN THE AFTERNOON AND
THEN I WOULD WORK AT U. C. P. A
LITTLE OF THAT WORKING IN OUR
PROGRAM SERVICES SIDE.
I'VE DONE EVERYTHING THERE FROM
PUSH THE BROOM DRIVING THE VAN
WORKING PROGRAM RAISING MONEY.
AND AGAIN FOR THE LAST TWENTY
SOME YEARS.
DIRECTOR AND GO HOME AND I
WONDER WHERE THE NEXT DOLLARS
COM.
SO WE'VE WE'VE BEEN HERE BUT
WE'VE NOT BEEN GREAT AT IT TERMS
SAFEGUARDING THAT'S A TWO SINCE.
WE'RE GONNA NEED YOUR HELP TO
CONTINUE ON THIS PATH.
AND I AGAIN I I APPLAUD WHAT
YOU'VE DONE.
BUT I THINK WE'RE THERE'S MORE
TO COME THERE'S MORE TO DO SO
I'M I'M GLAD TO SEE THE HAVE
NOTS.
THAT'S A GOOD THING SO.
WE'RE THERE WE'RE NOT GOING
ANYWHERE THIS IS OUR SIXTY FIRST
YEAR.
SERVICE IN THE SENIOR.
AND YOU GET TO DO THAT BECAUSE
YOU HAVE THE SUPPORT OF A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PEOPLE INCLUDING OUR
REGIONAL CENTER INCLUDING.
OUR LEGISLATORS IN SACRAMENTO.
AND IT WON'T WORK UNLESS THAT
CONTINUE SO I WOULD ONLY.
YOUR SEATS -- BUT KEEP GOING I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT IS OUR
MOST VULNERABLE CITIZENS.
THEY DESERVE OUR RESPECT AND
THEY DESERVE OUR HEART.
THANK YOU -- SUPER I LOVE BEING
ON MICROPHONES.
HI AM ARTS SOME TO SOME THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE ARK OF
IMPERIAL VALLEY.
WHERE ON LOCAL MEMBER UNIT OF
THE ARK?
WE WERE STABILIZATION TEEN.
SEVENTY THREE AND THIS TUESDAY
WAS MY TWENTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF
BEING WITH THE ARK IN CENTRAL
THANK YOU.
WE OPERATE -- DAY PROGRAMS
TRANSPORTATION GROUP HOMES.
ADULT PROGRAMS SPECIFICALLY.
EVERY SINGLE OF MY PROGRAMS HAS
A WAITING LIST.
WE SERVE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
CONSUMERS.
ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS THE WAITING
LIST WITH THE EXCEPTION OF OUR
HOMES.
LIKE CARLOS MEN IN THERE TO
CULTURAL ISSUE.
THE IMPAIR VALLEY IS 90% --
MEXICAN LATINO SO THERE'S AN
ISSUE THAT A LOT OF FAMILY
MEMBERS DO NOT LIKE THE IDEA.
ON SO IT KIND OF RELATES WHAT
CARDS WITH SAME.
I WANT TO SHARE SOMETHING THAT I
THINK IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE ARE
FROM A RURAL COMMUNITY.
IT'S THE WORD IS EMPLOYMENT.
RIGHT NOW THE IMPAIR THE ONLY
HAS AN ON WOMEN EIGHT OF 16% AS
A SUMMER COMES UP IT'S ONLY
GONNA JUMP TO TWENTY IT'S BEEN
OVER -- TWENTY FIVE AND THERE'S
TWO THINGS THAT I REALLY WANT TO
DRILL DOWN.
FIRST OF ALL AS MY PARTNERS HAVE
BEEN MENTIONING THE ON THAT
THERE'S ONLY ONE PATH FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT WE SERVE IN THE TWO
PROGRAMS.
AND THAT FULL EMPLOYMENT.
AT 16% UNEMPLOYMENT IT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT FOR US FIND PLACEMENT
FOR A LOT OF OUR PEOPLE.
OUR ARK HAS OPENED BUSINESSES TO
PROVIDE EMPLOYMENT FOR PEOPLE WE
OPEN UP AN ENTERTAINMENT CENTER.
WE HAVE TWO RESTAURANTS PLUS A
COMMERCIAL KITCHEN IT SOUNDS
GROOVY THAT WE DO ALL THIS STUFF
BUT IT'S JUST MORE HEADACHE FOR
US BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW
RESTAURANTS ARE.
ARE DIFFICULT.
ON TUESDAY WAS A GOOD DAY YES HE
WAS A BAD DAY.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE DO TO TRY TO
KEEP THINGS GOING IT'S DIFFICULT
TO FUND RAISE WHEN.
THERE'S JUST THAT MUCH LITTLE
POT.
AND THE OTHER ISSUE THAT I WANT
TO BRING UP HAVING TO DO WITH
UNEMPLOYMENT IN EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF MY STAFF WORKS THE GROUP HOME.
IS WORKING OVERTIME.
TODAY WE HAD -- INTERVIEWS. SIX
PEOPLE DIDN'T SHOW UP.
OURS CONSUMERS ARE OLDER NOW WE
FAIL AND THE AMOUNT OF WORK THAT
THEY KNOW THEY HAVE TWO VERSES
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT WE PAY.
PEOPLE ARE NOT SHOWING UP.
AND IT'S SCARY FOR US BECAUSE
YOU KNOW WE CAN ONLY DO SO MUCH.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE KEEP
THAT IN MIND THAT WE NEED TO DO
SOME THINGS SO THAT THE WE CAN
ATTRACT.
QUALIFIED PEOPLE TO PROVIDE VERY
VERY IMPORTANT SERVICES AS
PROVIDERS USUALLY GET THE IDEA
THAT THERE'S MORE AND MORE
WANTED FROM US MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
MORE PROFESSIONALISM BUT THE
MONEY THAT WE HAVE TO HIRE
PROFESSIONALS.
NOT REALLY THERE -- FOR EXAMPLE
IN MY ARC WE HIRE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE STUDIED IN THE
STATE.
BUT HAVE DECIDED TO LIVE THAT
MEXICO.
BECAUSE WHAT WE PAY IF YOU LIVE
IN MEXICO YOU CAN YOU CAN DO
WELL [INAUDIBLE]
COMFORTABLY.
MAYBE THEY WOULDN'T GET THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY OR SO WE GET A LOT
OF PEOPLE FRESH A COLLEGE THAT
HAVE STUDIED IN MECCA -- WHAT
ARE AMERICAN CITIZENS AND THEY
GET THEIR FEET WET WITH US?
IN BE NICE AND ONCE IN AWHILE WE
CAN GET PEOPLE IN WHO ARE VERY
VERY EXPERIENCE IN THE FIELD IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT'S JUST REALLY WHAT I
WANT TO DRILL DOWN.
THE CONCEPT OF YOU KNOW REGIONAL
CENTER.
IT IS A REGIONAL SITUATION.
BUT I DO APPRECIATE ALL THE
SUPPORT THAT WE'RE GETTING FROM.
FROM CARLOS AND REGIONAL CENTER
HE'S NICE ENOUGH TO BRING SOME
OF THE PROVIDERS DOWN TO THE
VALLEY.
SO WE CAN ALL SHARE WHAT WE'RE
ALL DAY.
AND OF COURSE.
ANYTHING THAT YOU WANNA KNOW
FROM OUR LITTLE -- THE WORLD
WILL BE GLAD TO SHARE
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE.
OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE PLEASE SIR.
I DO HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS --
AND AGAIN IT GOES TO THE THE
CRUX OF THE AMOUNT OF OF PEOPLE
THAT YOU SERVE.
AND THE EMPLOYEES THAT YOU HAVE.
AND RETENTION RATE.
WHAT IS YOUR WHAT IS YOUR KNEE
WHAT IS YOUR CRITICAL NEED OF
EMPLOYEES RIGHT NOW AS WE SPEAK?
IN A LOT OF THE PEOPLE LIKE YOU
SAID THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND.
AND WHAT'S THE NUMBER RIGHT NOW
IF YOU HAVE THERE'S SOME WERE
WORRIED SAID.
YOU HAD ONE WISH WHAT WOULD THAT
NUMBER BE.
IN ORDER FOR ME TO SATISFY
EVERYBODY THAT'S ON A WAITING
LIST OVER.
TWENTY FIVE DAVE HELLO YOU.
ARE NOT.
OLD BUT IN PROBLEMS BOB.
PEOPLE PROGRAM SERVICES HI.
YOUR PROGRAM SERVICES ARE PUT
FORTH BY YOUR STAFF THAT THAT IS
YOUR PROGRAM -- THE PHILOSOPHY
IS THERE AND YOU NEED TO HAVE
THE BEST PERSON THERE THE SAFEST
PERSON THE MOST TRAIN PERCENT.
BUT TO DO THAT AGAIN YOU HAVE
PEOPLE WHO'S WHO IN CASES HAVE
COLLEGE DEGREES SOMETIME VANCE
DEGREES.
WHO ARE LOOKING [INAUDIBLE]
FOR VERY MUCH.
AND IT'S HARD TO KEEP.
RETAIN THEM SO THERE IS NO.
THAT'S NOT WE'RE NOT FACING SO
MUCH WHAT ARTISTS FEES.
FACING THERE BUT WE DO HAVE
TURNOVER RATES THERE HAVE BEEN
TIMES WHERE IT HAS BEEN AS HIGH
AS 30% TERMS OF DIRECT CARE
PROFESSIONALS [INAUDIBLE]
BUT ARE WE NOW KNOW I'D I I'D
HAVE TO HONESTLY THAT WERE NOT
BUT IT'S ABOUT KEEPING PEOPLE
YOU WANT PEOPLE TO BUILD A
CAREER TO MOVE FORWARD IN IN IN
THE CHAIR SO TO SPEAK.
AND TO BRING THEIR EXPERTISE AND
THEN TRAIN THE NEW PEOPLE THAT
WANT TO BE INVOLVED IN MAKING --
WHAT THEY'RE DOING AT PLACES
LIKE YOU SEE P. AND THE ARK?
A LOT OF OTHER PROVIDERS THAT
ARE OUT HERE TONIGHT THEIR
CAREER THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE
COMMITTED IN.
ONE SO WE HAVE TO GIVE ME A
REASON TO STAY -- JUST A ABOUT
[INAUDIBLE]
IT.
AND I KNOW IT'S HARD TO RECRUIT
IMPERIAL VALLEY.
YOU HAVE A LIKE -- AN
INSTITUTION AT LEAST IN TERMS OF
PROVIDING.
EDUCATED TRAIN POSTERS I THINK
YOU HAVE A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
INTERFERE VALLEY UP TO LEAVE
THIS WITH YOU.
DON'T HAVE TO SEE ISSUE OTHER
THAN -- THERE'S STATE THERE'S A
SATELLITE CAMPUS SO SEND IT WAS.
WHICH BY THE WAY I TEACH THERE.
YOU HAVE A AND I I CAN'T
REMEMBER WHAT'S IN THE SATELLITE
CAMPUS I KNOW THAT EDUCATION IS
A PART OF IT.
SENATE BECAUSE THEY FOR YEARS
BUT DO THEY HAVE ANYTHING ELSE
IN TERMS OF THAT THAT COULD KIND
OF BEAT YOU IN TERMS OF
PROVIDING THERE IS A PSYCHOLOGY
MAJOR AND WE DO.
STUDENTS THAT -- INTERESTED SOME
OF MY STUDENTS WHICH IS EXCITING --
BUT YEAH MOST OF THE PEOPLE OF
THE ONE OF WORK WITH US.
IS JUST BECAUSE SOMETHING IN THE
SENATE I WANT TO TRY THIS.
THERE'S NOT A WILL BE A CLEAR
PATH [INAUDIBLE]
EDUCATIONALLY WISE.
WELL ARE TAKEN AND UNDERSTOOD
YOU KNOW AND APPRECIATE WHAT YOU
GUYS THERE'S A SPECIAL PLACE IN
HEAVEN FOR YOU GUYS SWEAR TO GOD.
THE THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND.
AND THE THE ACTUAL PROVIDERS.
AND THE SERVICE OF THE EMPLOYERS.
CAN'T THANK YOU ENOUGH FOR
HANGING IN THERE WITH US AND AND
BELIEVING THAT.
ARE WORKING DILIGENTLY IN
SACRAMENTO TRYING.
TO MOVE THE NEEDLE EVERY DAY AS
YOU SAID THERE WERE STRIDES THIS
YEAR.
THERE WERE STRIDES AND I THINK
THAT THERE IS.
A A RENEWED FAITH THAT WE CAN
GET THERE WITH THIS RATE STUDY
KNOWING THAT.
WE NEED ADVOCACY IN IN THE
CAPITAL WE WE CAN'T DO IT ALONE.
WE NEED PEOPLE IN SACRAMENTO.
WISHING OTHER LEGISLATORS AND
THE ADMINISTRATION [INAUDIBLE]
EDUCATE.
NOT USE A MOTION BUT ACTUAL
BUSINESS PERSPECTIVE. TO EDUCATE.
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE VOTING.
AND DETERMINING THE OUTCOMES OF
THE EFFORT.
SO LOOK FOR TO HEAR OF X. IN
SACRAMENTO ALSO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE WE
HAVE THREE SELF ADVOCATES WHO
ARE GOING TO TELL US.
THEIR STORIES I LOVE THIS PART.
TODAY WE HAVE WITH US CAN ROCKER
CLIENT OF THE SAN DIEGO REGIONAL
CENTER SUSAN MADISON.
FAMILY MEMBER AND BOARD MEMBER
OF THE STATE CAPITOL IN
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
AND TERRY OF BUSH'S COAL YES A
PARENT AND FORMER BOARD CHAIR OF
ARCA.
NO THREE COME UP AND WILL JUST
GO IN ORDER.
WE'LL START OFF WITH SUSAN
[INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
IN MOST ARE WITH YOU
[INAUDIBLE]
GOOD EVENING.
M. THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. FOR
MOST I WANT TO THANK YOU GUYS.
OUR COMMITMENT TO SUPPORT IN OUR
POPULATION.
AND I WANTED ALSO.
I'M HERE IS AND WE'RE OF
SPOKESPERSON KIND OF BUT I WANT
TO THANK TO PROVIDERS.
WITH THEIR EFFORTS.
AND I KNOW ONE IS THERE BE IS
CONCERNED IS THERE.
THE THE PAY RATE GOING FOR THAT.
IT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE THERE IS
A TURNOVER AS YOU SAID MY NAME
IS KIMBERLY RECORD OR CAN'T
MATCH MY FULL NAME.
AND I HAVE BEEN APPLYING TO
REGIONALS AND WROTE WORTH.
THIRTY PLUS YEARS.
AND THROUGHOUT THE YEAR I HAD
SAID ON THE BORDER DIRECTORS YOU
REACH CENTER IN THE NINETIES.
I AM ALSO HAD.
ORDERED AS A GROUP HOME FOR A
WHILE IN MY LIFE.
I HAVE HAD THE SUPPORT OF THE
JOB GOES -- THROUGHOUT MY LIFE
RIGHT NOW MY BIG WELL IS THE IS.
THE GETTING INTO THE CELL
TERMINATION BECAUSE I DON'T FIT
IN THAT LITTLE BOX.
THEY ALL HAVE WILL GET A PROGRAM
STILL OR IN -- GROUP HOMES THERE
WOULD LIKELY I HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
MOVE IN WITH PAUL AND
INDEPENDENT LIVING.
I DO HAVE AND I'LL LIST WE'RE
AND IN THE GLEE I'VE BEEN
BLESSED BECAUSE I'VE HAD THE
SAME PERSON FORTY YEARS.
BUT THAT WAS THE CASE BEFORE.
YOU HAVE THE TURNOVER SO YOU
GUYS WANT ME TO TRUST.
THESE PEOPLE THAT ARE COMING IN
AND HELPING [INAUDIBLE]
BACK [INAUDIBLE]
MY I LAKE REGAINING IN DECEMBER
ONLY USE HERE.
AND FOR ME TO OPEN UP
[INAUDIBLE]
WE NEED -- HE DAY WALL.
N. B. SUPPORTING.
ON EIGHT OR WHATEVER. TO BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT AT WE DO HAVE.
COLONEL WERE I WOULD LIKE IT I
WAS ABLE TO WORK IN THE WORLD
FOR FIVE YEARS.
THE TURNOVER IN JOB COACH IS WAS
AMAZING.
AS IN -- SLEEP AGAIN NO WHO WAS
COME IN ONE DAY I KNEW IT WAS
COMING YOU KNOW THEY WERE TO BE
THERE FOR AWHILE.
AND THEN USE WHICH PERSON SO
THEN YOUR TRAINING THAT PERSON.
THEY DO HELP YOU DO YOUR JOB.
BASICALLY WHAT HAPPENS I DO MORE
TRAINING OF THE PEOPLE THAT I
WORK WITH.
THEM THEM KNOWING THEIR JOB.
BEFORE THEY COME TO ME SO IT'S
LIKE NO WE DO THIS THIS AND THIS
AND THIS.
THIS IS HOW WE WORK TODAY THIS
IS OUT EMOTIONS ARE GOING
TOMORROW.
IN A ROW.
IF THE WORLD WAS GHOST YOU'RE
RIGHT TIME -- I AM OF THE STRONG
SELF ADVOCATE.
I AM INVOLVED IN SAN DIEGO
PEOPLE WORKERS.
THE INTERNATIONAL ORGANISED AGE.
GROUP PEOPLE WANT.
TO INSTABILITIES NINETY X. H. E.
L..
I AM SECOND TERM I HAVE BEEN IN
PRO PROGRAM WITH OVER TWENTY
YEARS.
AND WE'RE GETTING READY TO HAVE
OUR TWENTY SEVEN AND OR THE
PEOPLE ARE PEOPLE FIRST.
AND ARE SEEN DAY HERE.
IS -- BLASTED VIEW HERE ARE
FEATURED HERE OUR CHOICE.
AND TO PUT ON THIS CAR. TO GET
THE PEOPLE TO THE SELF LEVEL
GETS TO COME TO THE PLANNING
MEETING.
IS VERY DIFFICULT BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE STAFF.
AND NOW TO BRING THESE PEOPLE
BECAUSE THEY'RE COMMITTED
ANOTHER AREA.
SO WE DON'T HAVE SO THAT WE GET.
PLANNING THE CONFERENCE
WEDNESDAY OFF RICH.
AND IN SEVEN JUST DEAL WITH THE
IN THERE CAN THEY'RE LIKE.
I DON'T ALWAYS NEED BY SUPPORT
PERSON.
SO OKAY I'M THERE BUT THAT DOES
IT GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR AS
THEIR DAY PROGRAMS OR GROUP
HOMES TO BRING THEIR PEOPLE.
PLAN THIS CONFERENCE WHICH IS
BASICALLY THEIR IT TOWARDS THEM.
AND THE REPRESENTATIVE THERE ONE
ANY WE HAVE.
THE ARM.
YOU KNOW WE RUN THE ENOUGH
SPEAKERS WE WE RAN THE AD.
BREAK OUT SESSIONS.
GETS PRETTY TOUGH.
IN YES WE ARE REGIONAL BACKING
US UP THERE.
ORDER BEEN WITH BUT I MEAN IT'S
VERY HELPFUL THE FUNDING WASN'T
THERE WE WOULD NEED WOULD BE
ABLE TO HAVE.
THE CONGRESS BECAUSE WE ONLY
HAVE.
EMAIL SUPPORT STAFF TO HELP ALL
THE TIME WE KNOW THE VOLUNTEERS
YOU MISTAKE.
NO ON THE DAY OF THE CAR RAN.
AND THEN WERE DIRECTED THEM ON
HOW TO HELP WITH.
THAT IS WHAT WE'RE DOING.
THE THE EDUCATION [INAUDIBLE]
THE STAFF.
AND IT WILL BE NICE TO HAVE
PEOPLE HAVE.
YOU RAISE THAT THEY NEED ONE
STICK AROUND FOR AWHILE.
AND BE A CONSTANT -- IN OUR
LIVES AND NOT JUST THE TEMPORARY.
CONS CONFIDENCE IN ME.
I THINK IT WITH YOUR GUISES HELP
IN WITH THE COMMUNITY SO.
WE CAN DO IT AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU GUYS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU CAN.
NEXT WE'LL MOVE ON TO SUSAN
MADISON SUSAN PLEASE YEP.
IT'S AN HONOR.
I GREW UP ON THE DISABILITY.
AND THAT REALLY FUELED MY
PASSION FOR ADVOCACY.
BOTH FOR MYSELF.
AND FOR OTHERS BUT DISABILITIES.
AND NOW I'M CHAIR OF THE ALSO ON
THE ROLE MODELS VOTED REGIONAL
VICE RE COMMITTEE. FOR SAN DIEGO
AND IMPERIAL SO WELCOME.
WE KNOW THE THOUSANDS RECEIVE
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS.
AND AS YOU KNOW THERE'S NO NEED
FOR MORE.
I ALSO ADVOCATE FOR AN EIGHT
YEAR OLD BOY.
HE HAS MULTIPLE DISABILITIES
NEUROLOGICAL.
YES APPALACHIAN HAS CEREBRAL
PALSY.
THAT BOYS MY GRANDSON.
AND HIS NAME IS CONOR.
ON ITS FIRST DAY OF LIFE HE WAS
RUSHED INTO EMERGENCY SURGERY
FOR A RUPTURED COLON SO WE'RE
VERY.
FOR AROUND HIM.
NOW I'M GLAD TO REPORT HE'S
DRIVING.
HE HAS A SOLID GOOD EDUCATION
MORE THAN INDIVIDUALIZED
EDUCATION PLAN AND I IN P..
AND IS GOING TO BE ENTERING
THIRD GRADE THIS FALL.
HIS PARENTS AT AND HIS
GRANDFATHER ALL HOPE YOU CAN
ATTEND COULD ALWAYS [INAUDIBLE]
VERY WORK.
I CAN LIVE INDEPENDENTLY.
ALWAYS SUPPORTS IT.
THOUGH SOME PARTS COST MONEY.
THIS ISN'T ROCKET SCIENCE.
STAFF AND DECENT MAN PROVIDERS
NEED A RATE INCREASE EVEN MORE
BUT YOU KNOW THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT.
AND YOUR HUNDRED AGAIN TONIGHT.
SO WHAT IS KIND NEED.
AND WHAT DO THOUSANDS WITH NO
ACTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES NEED.
AS THREE BULLETS.
I BELIEVE THEY NEED YOUR HELP.
TO ENSURE THE MONEY FROM THE
CLOSURES OF VALEMOUNT CENTERS.
REMAINS AND A DEDICATED HOUSING
FUND. TO SUPPORT INTEGRATED
COMMUNITY HOUSING.
I THINK IT'S CRITICAL.
AND IT WOULD BE VERY VERY
[INAUDIBLE]
NOT OKAY. TO PUT THAT MONEY INTO
GENERAL FUND THAT'S MY PERSONAL
OPINION.
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS ARE
SITTING ON PRIME PROPERTY IS
WORTH EIGHT TONS OF MONEY.
THOSE MUST REMAIN IN A DEDICATED
HOUSING.
AND I THINK YOU CAN I ABOUT
MARCUS.
WHAT ELSE IS NEEDED?
THE OPTION TO CONTROL SERVICE
DOLLARS THROUGH SELF
DETERMINATION.
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES MUST BE
GIVEN THE TOOLS THAT.
YOUR PERSON CENTERED PLANNING.
IN OTHER WORDS IF YOU'VE NEVER
HAD A CHOICE YOUR ENTIRE LIFE
SOMEBODY COMES UP AND SAYS SO
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO.
YEAH I DON'T KNOW YEAH.
ARE.
SO THAT TOOLS MUST BE THERE.
AND IT HAS TO BEGIN TO SHARE.
AND I'M NOT WITH PILOT THEN WE
HAD MORE PILOTS WE HAD A PILOT
SEVEN YEARS AGO NOW IN ANOTHER
PART OF SELF DETERMINATION YEAH
YEAH YEAH YEAH.
WE NEED MORE.
LAST WHAT ELSE DO PEOPLE MADE I
THINK THE FATE AND COMPETITIVE
[INAUDIBLE]
EMPLOYMENT.
HOW LONG Ó LORD [INAUDIBLE]
AMEN [INAUDIBLE]
AMEN.
WHAT WE KNOW?
WE KNOW THROUGH DEIRA THAT 13%
OF CALIFORNIANS WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES.
ARE APPLIED COMPARED 275% OF THE
GENERAL POPULATION.
I'M GONNA REPEAT THAT. 13%.
OF CALIFORNIAN OF INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
ARE EMPLOYED.
COMPARED 275%.
OF THE GENERAL POPULATION
[INAUDIBLE]
SHOP.
LAPSED WE NEED TO EMPOWER
INDIVIDUALS IT'S YOUNG.
THE ORIGINAL CENTERS MISSION YET.
WE NEED TO NOT JUST TAKE CARE OF
PEOPLE.
WE HAVE BEEN DOING THAT A LONG
TIME.
DISABILITY RIGHTS ARE CIVIL
RIGHTS.
ARE YOUR FAVORITES HERE WOULD
TELL YOU HE'S HAPPY.
ANY AS DRONES JUST LIKE
EVERYBODY ELSE.
HI DOESN'T NEED A HANDOUT.
HE NEEDS A HAND UP.
OVER THE YEARS WE'VE MADE MUCH
PROGRESS BUT I'M THRILLED.
BUT THERE REMAINS MUCH.
ZERO WE NEED TO ENSURE THE
RIGHTS AND EQUALITY FOR PEOPLE
OF AN ELECTION IN THE RUBBLE
MODES OF THE USER REALIZED AND
TOGETHER.
WE CAN MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
WE ARE MAKING IT HAPPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU [INAUDIBLE]
I I HAVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL.
HEARING THIS AND GIVE US
ADDITIONAL MOTIVATE -- AND
SACRAMENTO BECAUSE YOU ARE BAD
FOR JUST THAT IN FOR YOU KNOW
WHAT I AM SCHOOL BOARD WHEREVER.
I WOULD BELIEVE THAT HAVE
PHILOSOPHY THAT AS A AS A
SOCIETY AS A COMMUNITY.
JUDGE.
NOT BY WHAT WE DO.
WHAT WE DO FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
OUR OLDER CITIZENS AND WHAT WE
DO FOR THOSE WITH THE SAME?
THAT IN TERMS OF QUALITY WE ARE.
AND ONLY ONE SERVER WAS BEING.
REALLY FULFILL OUR HUMANITY.
HELLO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YEAH THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
I DO WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU AS
IS SEMI MEMBERS ALL ON HER WAY
OUT THAT SHE WAS ON THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
AND WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
ADVANCEMENT WE MADE THIS YEAR IN
THE BUDGET FOR THE FOR THE IDG
COMMUNITY IN LARGE PART WAS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHIRLEY WEBER
WHO MADE.
REMOVE UNDER TERRY AND TERRY
THESE [INAUDIBLE]
HELLO.
THANKS FOR HAVING US ALL HERE
TONIGHT -- I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS
YOUR FAVORITE PART IT MIGHT BE
BECAUSE WERE LIKE SUPER
PASSIONATE AND DON'T GET PAID.
RIGHT I DON'T KNOW I LIKE WHAT I
DO YEAH YEAH WELL -- I DIDN'T I
JUST SAY REALLY QUICK THE PEOPLE
LIKE YOU KNOW SENDING STILL HERE
SINGING MARTIN.
AND AT WORK FROM HOME WORK
ANYMORE.
AND SOMEONE LIKE MYSELF WE HAVE --
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A VESTED
INTEREST IN A WE HAVE FAMILY
MEMBERS.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THERE ARE SO
MANY PEOPLE IN THE SYSTEM AND
HAVE NOTHING THEY HAVE.
NOTHING TO DO THEY HAVE NO
FAMILY MEMBERS AND THEY'RE JUST
AS PASSIONATE AS WE ARE ABOUT
SERVING.
THE COMMUNITY AND I JUST THINK
THAT IT REALLY BLOWS ME AWAY --
MY NAME'S TERRY CLUTCHES THEY
SAID AND I USUALLY DON'T LIKE A
SCRIPT THAT ON I TEND TO TALK A
LOT IN CURLESS ENCOURAGED ME.
TO TYPE IT OUT SO.
I DON'T I WANT TO GET THE HOOK
FROM YOU GUYS EVERYTHING HER.
SO.
I HAVE A DAUGHTER THAT'S TWENTY
YEARS OLD SHE SEVERELY IMPACTED
WITH AUTISM SHE'S NONVERBAL SO
SHE'S ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE THAT.
IT'S VERY HARD TO SERVE ON ONE
OF THE LEAD CARLOS TALKING ABOUT
NEGOTIATED RATE HOMES THAT'S
THAT'S HER.
AND A LOT OF TIMES.
YOU GUYS ON HERE ABOUT THAT PART
OF THE POPULATION BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT REALLY ABLE.
TO REPRESENT THEMSELVES AT ALL
AND I CAN EVEN BRING HER HERE I
COULD BUT YOU BE THROWING MONEY
JUST.
TO HAVE A SLEEVE.
BUT THE REGIONAL CENTER -- IS
SERVING HER SINCE SHE WAS EIGHT
MONTHS OLD -- HAVE TO SAY THAT.
THE TWO WERE INSTRUMENTAL AND
BEING THERE FOR OUR FAMILY AND
FOR HER WHEN WE REALLY NEED THE
HELP I MEAN.
THAT REALLY SERVER YOU'RE
FALLING APART REGIONAL CENTERS
THERE AND THEY'RE ACES THEY
THEIR PEOPLE THERE ARE GREAT --
I HAD SUCH A GREAT EXPERIENCE
WITH -- EVERYBODY THAT I CAME IN
CONTACT WITH WILSON GREAT CASE
WORKER.
AND SO I JUST DECIDED.
YOU KNOW IT I'M SO HAPPY WITH.
THE SERVICES I WOULD JOIN THE
BOARD SO I GOT ON THE BOARD IN --
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE HE SERVED AS
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD THERE --
I WAS ON THE BOARD ARE GAS OR
WITH SUSPICION A REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES -- FOR FIVE YEARS AND
SERVED AS A PRESIDENT THERE.
AS I A LOT OF WORK EXPERIENCE IN
ADDITION TO THAT AND I AM TO
TELL YOU THAT -- IN ALL THE
YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN ON FOR ITS --
THERE'S NO.
BETTER MORE THAN SAY REGIONAL
CENTER NO BETTER ORGANIZATION
AND I CAN SEE THAT THE STATE
LEVEL VERY EDUCATION LEVEL OF
KNOWING ALL THE DIFFERENT
REGIONAL CENTERS AND THE WAY
THEY'RE RUN.
UNTIL YOU SAN DIEGO IS.
IN MY OPINION THE BEST ONE THE
STATE I THINK WE MAYES IN BOARD
THE WORD REALLY WORKS WELL THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WE YOU KNOW
REALLY TRY TO BRAINSTORM IDEAS
COME UP WITH SOLUTIONS ENTREE B.
GENERATIVE COME UP WITH.
YOU KNOW DIFFERENT THINGS IN
DIFFERENT WAYS TO DO THINGS -- I
THINK OF HOLDING LANTERN ACT IS
IS REALLY SO CRITICAL AS A LOT
OF THESE PEOPLE HAVE SAID BEFORE
ME -- IT'S CRITICAL TO OUR
CLIENTS FOR THEIR SAFETY OTHER
SECURITY THEIR HAPPINESS AND
INTEGRATION BETWEEN A. S. ALSO
CRITICAL FOR THE FUTURE OF OUR
SYSTEM.
AND FOR OUR CLIENTS.
HER SON MOST VULNERABLE CITIZENS
OUT THERE -- WE'RE HERE TO SERVE
THE COMMUNITY IN OUR COMMITMENT
IS STEADFAST BUT WE YOU KNOW
THEY THEY REALLY NEED US NAY IS
TO PUSH IT.
ON THE ADVOCATE FOR THEM AND FOR
THE QUALITY OF LIFE -- AND I'M
GONNA ECHO IT'S TERRIBLE WHEN
LAST BECAUSE SOMEBODY'S EVERY
SENSE THING BUT I DO THINK THAT
ONE OF THOSE CRITICAL.
CRITICAL GLARING FOR ALL DAY
EVERYBODY'S TOUCHED ON IS THAT
THE MOST IMPORTANT PEOPLE IN IN
THE LIVES OF OUR CHILDREN OUR
CLIENTS OTHER THAN THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS. SIX WORKERS.
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT ARE MOST
CRITICAL DIRECT CARE TO OUR KIDS
IN OUR FAMILY MEMBERS.
IT'S A REALLY HARD JOB.
I IN I DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW THEY
DO IT THERE IF THEY'RE THE ONES
THAT ARE IN.
BUT IT IS VERY DIFFICULT FOR
THEM TO FOR FOR FOR WRITERS BE
ABLE TRACKS PEOPLE THE WANT THIS
JOB.
AND THEN IN THE GRITTINESS
PEOPLE AND YOU KNOW LIKE SHE WAS
SAYING IT'S JUST IT'S REALLY
HARD WHEN.
YOU'RE SOMEONE AND SO VULNERABLE
PENDING ON THESE PEOPLE TAKE
CARE OF YOU THE NEXT DAY YOU GET
UP IN THE STREET YOUR GIVE YOUR
SHOWER.
OKAY YOU KNOW BECAUSE THE ARRAYS
SO.
WHICH IS YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S A
REAL PROBLEM SO I THINK THAT.
IN THE SERVICE FOR RIDERS ARE
EXCELLENT BUT USING THE BEST
THEY CAN WITH WHAT THEY HAVE AN
ON AND THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME.
INJECTING A SHIFT -- PEOPLE WE
UNDERSTAND A COMPASSION OF THAT
SITUATION BECAUSE TO ME THAT'S
THAT'S REALLY THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING IS YOU KNOW TO GET THAT.
CONTINUITY AND OF CARE.
GIVING AND TO BE ABLE TO RETAIN
TRAINED STAFF THAT ARE THERE FOR
THE RIGHT REASONS AND THAT. FOR
YOU KNOW WORK THERE -- SEE.
I DON'T KNOW I THINK I THINK
SENIOR REGIONAL CENTER IN OUR
PROVIDERS ARE REALLY ACCENT LIKE
I SAID.
AND AS SOMEONE THAT HAS SERVED
THE STATE LEVEL AND I DO THINK
IT.
WAS IN THIRTEEN EIGHTY AN
AMAZING JOB.
BUT THE SYSTEM IS IN REAL
TROUBLE I MEAN IT'S SCARY SKIP
TROUBLE FOR FOR IT [INAUDIBLE]
AND FOR CLIENTS STATEWIDE.
SYSTEM STRETCH THE LIMITS AND I
THINK.
MANY PARENTS AND FAMILY MEMBERS.
THIS OF THEIR I SAY WE NEED A
TERM.
COMMUNITY BASED SOLUTION FAMILY
MEMBERS WERE AFRAID FUTURES.
THERE'S NO NEED TO BE PERHAPS
PROPER VIOLENCE IN THE TO HER BY
THE QUALITY CARE THEY WILL KEEP
OR A FAMILY MEMBER SAFE.
SECURE AND WELL CARED FOR BY
KIND PATIENT WELL TRAINED STAFF
IS EVERY PERSON DESERVES THE
BEST YEP ANSWER SPONSORED REALLY
MAKE IT HAPPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- IS THE
RESONATING -- MY DEAL IS BEEN
COMING FROM WE'VE DONE EIGHT
HEARINGS NOTES ROTH CYNICAL FROM
WAS UP READING EUREKA.
OF COACHELLA EVEN AND JUST TO
SHARE WITH YOU THIS IS BEEN IT
IS.
IT'S A PATTERN.
AND WE GET IT.
I HAVE ELEVEN BILLS THIS YEAR
THAT WERE DEDICATED TO THE ID
DEPOPULATION.
AND THEY WERE KILLED.
SO INNOVATIVE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT TAX CREDITS FOR
EMPLOYMENT READY POPULATION.
WE'RE NOT DONE AND WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GIVE UP.
WE'RE GONNA RE INTRODUCES BILLS
WE'RE GONNA USE A WORKFORCE
WE'RE GONNA USE THE POPULATION.
TO MOVE FORWARD ON THAT PROCESS
NEXT YEAR.
THAT YOU HAVE MONEY.
I AM YOU'LL GET A CHANCE -- MY
PROMISE THE WILL CONTINUE THE
EFFORTS BUT AND I HAVE TO TELL
YOU.
YOU'RE MY INSPIRATION.
MY ABSOLUTE INSPIRATION
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
SO I'M A FRESHMAN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND I WAS ON THE COUNCIL
ANTHONY IS FOR TWO YEARS AND SO
I HAVE EXPERIENCE FROM MY OWN
LIFE EXPERIENCE AND FROM THE PTA.
AND I SERVED ON FOR MY KIDS
SCHOOL -- AND SO FOR ME I I'M
LEARNING SO MUCH TODAY I WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY FOR SHARING
THEIR EXPERIENCES.
YOU'VE TAKEN TIME OUT OF YOUR
EVENING AND AND TRAVELED HERE TO
SHARE WITH US.
AND SO I'M LEARNING AND I'M
HEARING YOU AND I WHEN I
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY FOR BEING
HERE TODAY THANK YOU.
SO I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT AS A
FRESHMAN -- TOUCHES NOT STUBBORN
SHE'S JUST DETERMINED
[INAUDIBLE]
OKAY [INAUDIBLE]
I CONSUMMATION.
BUT YOU SEND SOMEBODY UP TO THE
CAPITAL THAT IS ABSOLUTELY IN
YOUR CORNER AND I WANT TO DO
THAT I APPRECIATE HER ALSO.
SO WE'RE GONNA GET THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS IN A FEW MINUTES ALL
WERE WE'LL HEAR FROM EVERYONE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK.
BUT FIRST WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM MARYLAND STUDS.
A SAN DIEGO IMPERIAL REGIONAL
MAP OF THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
[INAUDIBLE]
MARYLAND.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
WELL I JUST LIKE TO SAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING AND THANK
YOU TERRY FOR MENTIONING WHEN
YOUR LAST THERE'S NOTHING LEFT
TO SAY -- I WILL TRY TO BE BRIEF
BECAUSE I'M SURE ARE REALLY
HEARING FROM THE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE COME HERE. TO EXPRESS THEIR
FEELINGS AND SENTIMENTS IS MOST
IMPORTANT TO YOU.
I'M JUST TO TOUCH ON A FEW
THINGS AND I DON'T WANT TO BEAT
A DEAD HORSE.
WHAT?
I DO WANT TO SAY THAT THE WHOLE
RAID ISSUE IS NOT SELF SERVING.
PROVIDERS ARE NOT COMING HERE
SAYING GIVE US MORE MONEY
BECAUSE WE WANT TO ENRICH
OURSELVES.
IS KIM POINTED OUT IT REALLY
AFFECTS THE QUALITY.
SO IF YOU CAN'T HAVE QUALITY
SERVICES.
IT'S REALLY FRUSTRATING -- YOU
KNOW SELF DETERMINATION MIGHT BE
A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
BECAUSE OF PEOPLE CAN HIRE THEIR
OWN STAFF.
DOES SHE NEED A PAY SCALE.
THEY MAY BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY GET
AWAY WITH SPENDING LESS.
ON CONSISTENT HELP THAT AS AND
POINTED OUT HIS DAUGHTER MIGHT
HAVE ACHIEVED HER OBJECTIVES HAD
SHE HAD CONSISTENT -- SUPPORTS
AND SERVICES.
SO YAY FOR SELF DETERMINATION.
AND THE ROLLOUT IS JUST UNDERWAY
HERE WE'VE GOT A GREAT TEAM OF
PEOPLE.
AND I DO WANT TO MENTION I THINK
EVERYONE IN THIS AUDIENCE IS
HERE BECAUSE OUR COMMUNITY IS
VERY COHESIVE -- WE MIGHT NOT
AGREE ON EVERYTHING ALL THE TIME
AND I'M KEY POINTS PEOPLE REALLY
DO COME TOGETHER.
AND CURLESS MENTIONED HOW THEY
SUPPORT VARIOUS EVENTS AND THE
TRULY DO SO WE HAVE A LOT OF
PARTNERS EVERY AGENCY DOES WHAT
THEY CAN'T.
WE'RE VERY SMALL AGENCY SO WE
REALLY COULDN'T ACCOMPLISH
NEARLY ANYTHING WITHOUT THE
SUPPORT OF OTHERS IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
SO PLEASE THE WAGE ISSUE AS YOU
KNOW GOTTA BE ADDRESS SOMEHOW.
THE RACE FOR PROVIDERS ARE JUST
I USED TO BE A PROVIDER.
AND I WAS A PROVIDER FOR TWENTY
SIX YEARS I WAS A SPECIAL ED
TEACHER PRIOR TO THAT.
SO I KIND OF HAVE A LITTLE BIT
OF EXPERIENCE AND A LOT OF AREAS
AFFECTING OUR POPULATION.
I'M EMPLOYMENT IS HUGE.
WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO ABOUT THAT
WE HAVE AN EMPLOYMENT FIRST
POLICY NOW WHICH I HOPE EVERYONE
SUPPORTS AND KNOWS ABOUT --
BASICALLY IT'S SAYING THAT.
OF COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT.
IS THE PREFERRED OPTION FOR
PEOPLE GETTING OUT OF THE
TRANSITION PROGRAMS IN SCHOOL.
AND WE REALLY NEED TO EMBRACE
THAT IN OFFER VOLUNTEER
OPPORTUNITIES AND INTERNSHIPS
THE PAID INTERNSHIP PROGRAM THAT
CAME OUT OF THE EMPLOYMENT FIRST
POLICY.
HOPEFULLY WILL ENCOURAGE MORE
EMPLOYERS -- TO EXPERIENCE
HIRING SOMEONE WITH AN
INTELLECTUAL OR DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY -- ATTITUDES ARE
STILL NOT WITH THE SHOULD BE.
AND NOW WE'RE GONNA CHANGE THAT
BY EXPOSURE BY REALLY GETTING TO
KNOW PEOPLE [INAUDIBLE]
I'M.
THERE'S OTHER PATHWAYS TO
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT.
AND CHARLIE MENTIONED HE WANTED
TO GO TO COLLEGE.
I'M NINE YEARS AGO WE STARTED A
PROGRAM CALLED PROJECT COLLEGE.
WHICH IS A GROUP OF IT IT STEMS
FROM A TRANSITION COMMITTEE WE
HOSTED AT OUR OFFICE.
AND ONE PARENT HAD A SON WHO WAS
STRUGGLING IN A SECONDARY
EDUCATION.
AND ESPECIALLY WITH THE INCREASE
IN STUDENTS ON THE AUTISM
SPECTRUM MANY OF THESE STUDENTS
ARE MORE THAN CAPABLE OF GOING
TO A CREDENTIALED POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITY.
ON THE DID LIKE SOME OF
INTERPERSONAL SKILLS IDENTITY
SKILLS THINGS OF THAT NATURE THE
ABILITY TO GO AND SEEK OUT THE
HELP THEY NEEDED.
SO WE PARTNERED WITH A LOCAL
COLLEGE.
AND WE RUN A ONE WEEK -- COLLEGE
LIVING EXPERIENCE WERE STUDENTS
GET TO LIVE IN THE DORMS THEY
HAVE A MEAL CURRENTLY TAKE
ACTUAL COLLEGE CLASSES.
AND WE'VE HAD SOME REALLY GOOD
SUCCESS IT'S VERY SMALL.
NOT TRYING TO BLOW IT OUT OF
PROPORTION WE ONLY TAKE TWELVE
STUDENTS.
BUT IT'S IT'S A START AND OUR
GOAL IS TO HAVE THE SCHOOL.
IS UNIVERSITY UNIVERSITY OF SAN
DIEGO IS WHO WE PARTNER WITH
ADOPT THIS IS A REGULAR OFFERING
THEY HAVE EVAN PROGRAMS EVERY
YEAR FOR FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENTS.
WHY NOT HAVE THIS -- SO THAT'S
JUST A SUGGESTION -- OUR
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES.
WE HAVE A HUGE EVENT LOCALLY
THAT'S A COMMUNITY COLLABORATIVE
OF ALL TYPES OF DISABILITIES.
PEOPLE THAT ARE BLIND PEOPLE
THAT ARE DEAF PEOPLE THAT ARE
WITH DEPARTMENT OF REHAB PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
I'M THIS YEAR EARLY HAN HAS
DONATED CHANGE ARENA FOR THIS
EVENT SO CLEARLY THERE IS --
SUPPORT IN THE COMMUNITY.
SO THAT'S AN AWESOME EVENT
HOUSING YEAH TO OTHER FOUNDATION
AND CARLOS FOR HAVING THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HOUSING
COLLABORATIVE.
BUT AS YOU KNOW THAT'S JUST A
SMALL BITE.
BECAUSE I PULLED THE STATISTICS
YESTERDAY FROM THE NATIONAL LOW
INCOME HOUSING COALITION.
AND IN CALIFORNIA WHAT THEY
CONSIDER TO BE AFFORDABLE RENT
FOR AN SSI RECIPIENT IS TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DOLLARS. FOR
A PERSON WITH A FULL TIME JOB
PAYING MINIMUM WAGE WOULD BE SIX
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR DOLLARS.
I'M I DON'T KNOW WHERE IN
CALIFORNIA YOU COULD FIND THAT
HOUSING [INAUDIBLE]
SO IT'S CRITICAL TO INCENTIVIZE
LANDLORDS PERHAPS.
HOUSING DEVELOPERS THERE NEEDS
TO BE SOME.
SOME GIVE SOMEWHERE BECAUSE IT'S
TWELVE YEAR WAIT LISTS FOR
SECTION EIGHT HOUSING AND EVEN
THEN IF YOU GET A VOUCHER TRY TO
FIND A LANDLORDS WILLING TO
ACCEPT IT.
IT'S NOT AS EASY AS ALL THAT WE
TELL PEOPLE YOU KNOW IF THEY ASK
FOR ADVICE SAY GET ON THE
WAITING LIST NOW GET ON THE
WAITING LIST WHEN YOU'RE.
EIGHTEEN OTHER NOT READY TO MOVE.
ALRIGHT.
I'M NOT GOING TO BE GETTING IT
TOMORROW.
MAYBE BY THE TIME THEY'RE THIRTY
THEY'LL GET A AN OPPORTUNITY TO
LIVE IN THE COMMUNITY.
SO IT'S A STRUGGLE -- WE DO THE
NATIONAL CORE INDICATOR SURVEY
SO WE GET FEEDBACK FROM AREAS
AGE RANGES DEPENDING ON THE YEAR.
THAT'S VERY INTERESTING WHEN YOU
HEAR WHAT FAMILIES ARE
EXPERIENCING.
AND INDIVIDUALS -- PROVIDE FIRST
HAND INFORMATION.
THERE DOES SEEM TO BE A LITTLE
BIT OF YOU KNOW FAMILIES ARE
REALLY.
EASY THEY THEY HAVE SO MUCH ON
THEIR PLATES SOMETIMES GETTING
THE INFORMATION THEY NEED IS NOT
READILY ACCESSIBLE TO THEM.
SO.
SOMEHOW IF THERE COULD BE SOME.
DATABASE SOMEWHERE OF OF
INFORMATION I KNOW THERE'S MANY
BUT TO REALLY STREAMLINE IT AND
GET IT INTO THE HANDS OF THE
FOLKS WHO STRUGGLE AND SAY I
NEVER KNEW.
YOU ASKED ME THIS QUESTION JUST
MY CHILD GET.
A RESPITE SERVICES I DIDN'T KNOW
I COULD ASK FOR IT.
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
SO SOMEHOW WE NEED TO REALLY
PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION -- AND
WHAT ELSE DID I WANNA TALK THAT
PROBABLY NOTHING I SHOULD HAVE
JUST GOTTEN APPEARANCES DITTO TO
EVERYTHING THAT WAS ALREADY SAID
BECAUSE YOU KNOW AGAIN IT'S IT'S
AN AWESOME COMMUNITY AND PEOPLE.
TRY PEOPLE STRUGGLE OF THERE'S
SO MANY PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM THAT
I'VE KNOWN FOR DECADES.
AND YOU KNOW WHEN PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT THE CONSISTENCY OF STAFF
WE'RE LOSING GOOD PEOPLE.
SO THAT'S UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S WHAT MAKES OUR
SYSTEM SO STRONG.
PEOPLE MIGHT NOT BE THE SAME
AGENCY THEY MIGHT GO TO A
DIFFERENT AGENCY THEY TAKE ALL
THAT KNOWLEDGE WITH THEM.
SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
BUILD THAT.
AND PROFESSIONAL LINES.
THIS IS A CAREER PATH.
YOU KNOW MANY MANY PEOPLE I KNOW
WHO ARE A PROVIDERS IN THIS
FIELD THEIR SONS OR DAUGHTERS
ARE NOT LOOKING TO JOIN THE WORK
FORCE.
THEY MAY DO VOLUNTEER WORK
[INAUDIBLE]
GENERAL.
EXCUSE ME BEEN FORCED TO DO
VOLUNTEER WORK.
AS WE DRAG THE WITH US
[INAUDIBLE]
BUT YOU KNOW THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO THEY'RE NOT GOING TO TAKE A
JOB IT'S NOT GOING TO PUT FOOD
ON THE TABLE [INAUDIBLE]
SOME.
THAT'S ABOUT IT -- AND I DID
WANT TO SAY -- PEOPLE FIRST NAY
HIM THANK YOU FOR MENTIONING
THAT.
REALLY -- EMPOWERING PEOPLE.
IS CRITICAL THOSE SELF ADVOCATES
IN FAMILY ADVOCATES TO SPEAK UP
FOR THEMSELVES AND TO DIRECT HOW
THEIR SERVICES ARE GOING.
AND I THINK YOU CAN TELL FROM
THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE SPOKEN.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE COMFORTABLE
SAYING WHAT THEY WANT AND KNOW
THEY MAY NOT GET EVERYTHING THEY
WANT ALWAYS BUT THEY KNOW THEY
CAN ASKING YOU NEGOTIATES LIKE
ANYTHING ELSE.
SO I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I'LL LET YOU TALK TO
THE PEOPLE WHO CAME HERE.
JUST SECOND JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT MY COLLEAGUE HAS ANY
QUESTIONS.
GOING FORWARD THANK YOU.
SO I YOU KNOW I JUST WANNA THANK
YOU MARYLAND FOR BEING HERE AND
YOUR PASSION AND COMPASSION.
FOR ALL OF OUR FRIENDS AND WE
BOTH.
ABSOLUTELY ADORE -- RESONATES
AGAIN THE THE COMPLETE NEED.
I WAS AN EMPLOYER I CALL USE AN
EMPLOYER WE UNDERSTAND RETENTION
AND AND PAYING DECENT AND GOOD
WAGES.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THROUGH THE HEARINGS THAT
I'VE HAD IS WORRIED KNOWLEDGE IN
THE FACT THAT WE NEED TRAINED
INDIVIDUAL.
IT MAKE A DECENT WAGE SO THEY
CAN.
HAVE A CAREER PATH.
BUT ALSO UNDERSTANDING THAT WE
HAVE AN EXPECTATION THAT WE
INVEST IN THESE INDIVIDUALS THEY
CARE FOR THE INDIVIDUALS THAT WE
CARE ABOUT.
ON A LEVEL ON THAT SAME LEVEL.
AND SO THERE'S A GIVEN TAKE
GOING THERE.
SO WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT
LEGISLATION IN THE UPCOMING YEAR
THE CREE CREE PASS IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
SUPPORT FOR THE INDIVIDUALS
GOING FORWARD.
IN THE BAY AREA WE HAVE AN 83%
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE.
AND SO UNDERSTANDING.
PEOPLE ARE MAKING TWENTY DOLLARS
AN HOUR AND THEY WILL COME BACK
DOWN.
TO MINIMUM WAGE BECAUSE
EVERYTHING ELSE PAYS MORE
[INAUDIBLE]
AND SO.
WE HAVE THE SERVICE PROVIDERS AT
A LACK.
OF HAVING EMPLOYEES BECAUSE IT.
IS CAN'T COMPETE.
YOU KNOW THERE USED TO BE A
PROGRAMMER CAN SEE THE AREA THAT
STARTED TO GROSSMONT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
AND WENT THROUGH IDEALLY TO A
PHD.
AND WE HAVE HIRED ONE OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO IS IN FACT NOW
PHD.
AND SHE'S AN INCLUSION
SPECIALIST IN THE SCHOOL THIS.
SO IT DOES WORK.
IF YOU CAN GET PEOPLE TO WHAT I
WILL SHARE WITH YOU MY DAUGHTER
WAS AN UNDERGRAD AT UC DAVIS.
AND SPENT TWO YEARS A TURNING
POINT IN SACRAMENTO WORKING WITH
THE ID POPULATION THEN CAME.
SAN DIEGO FOR HER MASTERS IN AN
INSIDE D. SHE'S AT SHARP
MEMORIAL HOSPITAL DOING CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGY.
BUT WHEN SHE CAME TO SAN DIEGO
I'VE NEVER HAD HER BACK.
IS THERE WHERE YOU REALLY HERE.
JUST SHARING WITH SHE LOVES YOU
COMMUNITY BUT SHE ALSO IS IS IS.
ABOUT THE THE POPULATION WHEN
SHE WORKED WITH THEM FOR TWO
YEARS SHE TO I WAS SO AFRAID
THAT SHE WAS GOING TO GO BACK TO
COLLEGE.
BUT SHE DID IN AND BUT WE WILL
NOT [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH VÀ.
WE WILL NOT GIVE UP.
GOOD SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOW WE'RE HERE PUBLIC COMMONS.
THIS IS WHERE WE HEAR FROM YOU.
SO COME ON UP TO THE MICROPHONE
WILL START A LINE RIGHT HERE.
OF IF YOU WANT TO SHARE YOUR
STORY TELL US YOUR NAME.
AND PLEASE IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME AND ENSURING EVERYBODY HAS
A CHANCE TO SPEAK.
YOU LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO TWO
MINUTES.
WHAT I WILL DO IS AFTER AFTER AT
IF WE STOP YOU TWO MINUTES WHEN
WE HAVE TIME LEFT OVER?
YOU CAN COME BACK UP TO THE MIKE
AND FINISH UP.
WE STATE YOUR NAME AND WHERE
YOU'RE FROM SIR.
HEY.
BOB GUTHRIE I'M FROM A EACH
COUNTY FROM EL CAJON.
AND I'M ALSO I SERVE ON DE.
PEOPLE'S FIRST WHAT THE ERROR
YOU BOARD THIRTEEN WENT -- JIM
WALKER NOR PARKER.
AND I I'VE BEEN WITH THE I WAS
WITH THE ARC FOR YEARS. FOR SO
MANY YEARS.
AND THEN THEY PLACED ME ON A
REGULAR JOB FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS.
I WORKED THERE FOR AT A AT A
COMPANY NAMED GEORGE TECH AND
APPROACH THAT THE SHOCK COMPANY
FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
I HAD A GOOD JOB COACH THROUGH
OUR REGIONAL CENTER HAS BEEN MY
PROVIDER.
EVEN WHEN I WAS CAME OUT FROM
THE INSTITUTION IN. NINETEEN
FIFTY THREE TO FIFTY NINE I WAS
AT BORDER BILL STATE HOSPITAL --
VICHY HOSPITAL WORD OF ONE THAT
THEY WANT TO SELL.
AND THEN THEY ALSO HAD CINEMA.
ORVILLE IS BECAME A LIKE A IT
WAS LIKE PATTON.
AND THEN I GOT SEVERAL OTHER
STATE HOSPITALS AROUND AS THAT'S
MOSTLY A QUOTA OF LIKE -- I KNOW
THEY GOT THE TASK A GIRL TO JUMP
IN HERE.
GEN A BARBER AREA.
AND MOST OF THOSE PLACES THAT
I'VE.
YOU KNOW I'VE HEARD OF THOSE
PLACES WHEN GOVERNOR PAT BROWN.
BEFORE JERRY BROWN EVEN COULD BE
BECAME GOVERNOR AND EVEN BEFORE
[INAUDIBLE]
RONALD REAGAN.
AND I REALLY WOULD LIKE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE YOU. TO BE ABLE TO
HELP SUPPORT OUR PEOPLE.
IN OTHER PEOPLE.
DATA SHOULD PROVIDE SERVICES FOR
US BECAUSE I'M WITH THE TAYLOR
PROGRAM I GOT A PERSON NAMED.
MERYL DESERVE REAL GOOD WORKERS
ARE [INAUDIBLE]
RATE WORKER.
CARLOS IS A GREAT.
CAR OWNERS A GREAT -- YOU KNOW
WITH REGIONAL CENTER AND IN
DEVRY MARSHALL WITH PEOPLE.
FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE THIS EVENING THANKS
FOR YOUR INPUT.
STATE YOUR NAME IN THE
REPRESENTING AWAY FROM HELLO MY
NAME IS LUCILLE LYNCH AND I'M A
PARENT OF TWO INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES.
AND I'M ALSO A FOUNDER OF
BEACONS NORTH COUNTY OR BEACON
ZINC IN CARLSBAD.
AND I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE I
WANT US TO THINK BEYOND STANDING
A REGIONAL CENTER A LITTLE BIT
BECAUSE I THINK THEY HAVE A
HEAVY BURDEN AS DO THEIR SERVICE
PROVIDERS. TO TRYING TO CREATE
SKILLS.
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO GO BACK
TO LOOK AT THE AD CODE IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT OUR DISTRICTS
HAVE EIGHT YEARS HIGH SCHOOL AND
ADULT TRANSITION PROGRAMS TO
EQUIP PEOPLE WITH SKILLS TO GET
A JOB.
AND FOR SOME REASON THAT'S NOT
HAPPENING.
SO I'D LIKE FOR YOU TO CONSIDER
POSSIBLY LOOKING INTO AN
AMENDMENT TO THE EDUCATION. FOR
PEOPLE DIPLOMA BOUND THEY HAVE
THIRTEEN COURSES THEY BASICALLY
ARE YOU SENSUALLY AND
EDUCATIONAL GUARANTEES.
OF ACCESS TO LANGUAGE FINE ARTS
AND SO FORTH TO GET THAT DIPLOMA.
IF YOU ARE NOT DIPLOMA BOUND
THERE'S NOT ONE SINGLE
EDUCATIONAL COURSE DEGREE UNDER
THE CODE AND I FEEL THAT NEEDS
TO CHANGE BECAUSE THE FUNDS AND
THE SUPPORT IN THE STAFF ROOM
PLACE TO BE DOING MAGICAL THINGS.
BUT RIGHT NOW IF YOU'RE AND
WHICH YOU KNOW THEY TO BE
PROGRAM OR OTHER PROGRAMS THERE
ARE NO COURSES ARE NO CURRICULUM
AND THE OUTCOMES OF REMAINED
ALMOST STAGNANT FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL DECADES.
SO I WOULD LIKE FOR THE ASSEMBLY
TO CONSIDER POSSIBLY HAVING
COURSES REQUIRED FOR NON DIPLOMA
STUDENTS OR TO HAVE A HYBRID OF
YOUR DIPLOMA DOWN BUT NEED
SUPPORT.
THAT INCLUDE COMMUNICATION
COMPETENCY SOCIAL AND SOFT
SKILLS SELF ADVOCACY VOCATIONAL
EXPLORATION SEX EDUCATION
PROBLEM SOLVING AND ASSISTIVE
TECHNOLOGY.
BECAUSE THEY SHOULD BE
GRADUATING FROM THESE PROGRAMS
EQUIPPED TO TRANSITION I THINK
THAT'S ONE OF THE ASSUMPTIONS
WERE MAKING THAT'S NOT IN PLACE.
AND BY DOING THAT YOU COULD
PROBABLY REDUCE THE CASELOAD FOR
IT PIECE TEACHERS ARE DOING
GREAT JOBS BUT AGAIN WE KEEP
HEARING HOW THERE AREN'T ENOUGH
TIME RESOURCES.
IF YOU HAVE THE STRUCTURE
CLASSES PEOPLE COULD LEARN
COLLABORATIVELY AND REDUCE THE
DEMAND ON THAT ARE YOU P.
PROCESS WHICH SOMETIMES DIVIDES
TEACHERS AND PARENTS.
I ALSO THINK YOU NEED TO LOOK AT
THE EL CAP FUNDING.
THEY'LL CUT FUNDING GIVES
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING ANOTHER
FUNDING FOR CERTAIN CATEGORIES
OF STUDENTS WHO NEED EXTRA HELP
AND THAT HAVE BARRIERS WHAT'S
HAPPENING KNOWS NON DIPLOMA
STUDENTS.
ARE NOT HAVING HIS EMPLOYMENT
OUTCOMES SO MIGHT MIGHT BE WORTH
CONSIDERING TIMES SOME OF THAT
EL CAP FUNDING TO EITHER
INCREASING DEPLOYMENT DOWN
STUDENTS FROM THE NON DIPLOMA
TRACKS OR DID T<C.CYAN> THAT SOMEHOW</C>
WITH EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES.
OKAY I'M SORRY -- AND ALSO
THERE'S A VARIETY OF OTHER
THINGS BUT I WILL WRITE YOU AND
LET YOU KNOW BUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IF YOU HAVE TIME AND LOVE
TO BE ABLE TO TALK TO YOU.
I ALSO JUST THEM AND THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS DANNY ANDERSON I
HAVE WILLIAMS SYNDROME -- I
THINK A LOT OF US SUFFER FROM
MONEY.
AND I THINK A LOT OF I THINK A
LOT OF PEOPLE.
SUFFER BECAUSE I SEE A LOT OF
PEOPLE OUT IN THE COMMUNITY AND
DOESN'T HAVE A LOT OF MONEY FOR
EXAMPLE FOR ME.
I LIVE IN AND SUPPORTED LIVING
NOW I USED TO LIVE WITH MY MOM.
I WAS GETTING MORE MONEY THAN
THAN I WAS IN SUPPORT OF LIVING.
I MAKE THREE NINE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE DOLLARS
[INAUDIBLE]
A MONTH.
THAT DOES NOT HELP ME WITH THE
STUFF THAT I NEED.
AND IT DOES NOT HELP ME WITH
WITH EVERYTHING ELSE THAT I NEED
LIKE MY HYGIENE PRODUCTS.
MY MY THOUGHT THAT I NEED.
AND I'M SUFFERING.
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE I DON'T
HAVE THAT MUCH MONEY AND WITH ME
SPECIAL WITH ME BEING WILL HAVE
SPECIAL NEEDS.
I CAN'T GET A JOB.
I DON'T KNOW I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE SOLUTION IS.
BUT I'VE TRIED TO LOOK FOR JOBS
AND NO ONE WILL HIRE ME BECAUSE
I DON'T HAVE A DIPLOMA PLUS.
I PLUS I HAVE A CERTIFICATE OF
COMPLETION.
THAT DOESN'T HELP ME EITHER
[INAUDIBLE]
SO.
I AM ASKING YOU GUYS IF YOU GUYS
CAN FIGURE OUT A SOLUTION. TO
HELP US TO GET MORE MONEY THAN
WE THAN WE NEED.
BECAUSE IT WILL HELP THE
COMMUNITY A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
HOMELESS.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T MAKE A LOT OF
MONEY.
SO I'M SPEAKING FOR EVERYBODY
THAT IS HOMELESS AND EVERYTHING.
IF YOU GUYS CAN SEE IT IN MY
EYES [INAUDIBLE]
THAT [INAUDIBLE]
I I'VE ALWAYS BEEN HOMELESS
BECAUSE BECAUSE THE RIGHT AND
EVERYTHING IS SO HIGH.
I WISH THERE WAS A PLACE WHERE.
WHERE ALL OF US CAN LIVE WHERE
THERE'S NOT LIKE?
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE RAISING
RENT OR LOWERING RENT OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
ANYTHING THAT I DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT.
SO I WAS WONDERING IF THERE WAS
A SOLUTION THAT YOU GUYS CAN DO.
BECAUSE I PAY SEVEN HUNDRED A
MONTH.
THE OTHER THE OTHER APARTMENT
BECAUSE THEY MOVED FROM.
I MOVE FROM TWO DIFFERENT
APARTMENTS AND I THINK IT'S
EXACTLY THE SAME AMOUNT.
I WAS WONDERING IF YOU GUYS CAN.
FIGURE OUT A SOLUTION FOR
SPECIAL NEEDS.
WHO LIVE IS AN APARTMENT COMPLEX?
WHO LIVES AND?
INDEPENDENTLY OR WITH THE
SUPPORT OF LIVING.
WONDERING IF.
THERE'S A PLACE WHERE WE CAN GO
THAT'S NOT [INAUDIBLE]
SO HIGH.
WE WE DO WE DO WE ARE YOU.
AND SO WHAT WE'D LIKE TO DO IS
MAKE SURE THE CARLOS HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH YOU.
AND MAKE THAT.
HE'S LEARNING YES I APPRECIATE
THE GIRLS.
AND YOU GIVE SOME FORMED OKAY
BUT I REALLY DO APPRECIATE YOU
COMING SHARING THAT.
WE NEED TO HEAR THAT.
YES BECAUSE THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME I AM SPEAKING TO YOU GUYS
ACTUALLY YOU DID GREAT THANK YOU
OKAY -- FROM AYE AYE MENTALLY
AIDS OF CORN OUT OF THIS MY
DAUGHTERS HERE JULIUS.
I AND TERRA HAS INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY SHE SOMEWHAT SHY SO
I'LL BE SPEAKING FOR HER.
HI ALL YES.
STARK -- SHE SAID A COMMUNITY
BASED A PROGRAM AND COUPLE
THINGS ONE IS AND YOU'VE HEARD
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF TURNOVER
WITH DIRECT.
SERVICE STAFF BECAUSE OF WAGES
AND ALSO.
HIS COMPRESSION -- ANOTHER.
HEY IF YOU DON'T CONTINUITIES
HOME HORTON.
HER POPULATION REALLY IMPORTANT --
OF AN ECLECTIC DIMENSION I'M
ALSO ON THE BOARD THE
CORPORATION AROUND TO REGIONAL
CENTER HERE SO.
THESE ARE MY COMMENTS PERSONALLY
THOUGH MOPPING UP THE BOARD --
JUST TWO ITEMS I'D REALLY LIKE
TO FOCUS ON ONE IS -- AND I KNOW
THIS IS NOT A POPULAR ITEM BUT
SOME.
FOLKS CANNOT COMPETE.
IN COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT OKAY AND IT IS VERY
VERY DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO HAVE
A JOB TRAINING SKILLS IN DAY
PROGRAMS.
BECAUSE THERE IS INTENSE
COMPETITION FOR THE VOLUNTEER
JOBS.
AND YOU KNOW.
WE WERE TOLD YEAH SHE COULD DO A
JOB OVER HERE BUT IT WOULD TAKE
TWO HOURS EACH WAY.
ON A BUS TO GET THERE OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
SO.
WHEN SHE WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL IN
IN TRANSITION SHE GOT A
WORKABILITY PROGRAM SHE COULD
WORK FOR A LOCAL RESTAURANT?
IN GET.
YOU KNOW AND AND GET THE
EXPERIENCE NOW SHE CAN'T.
I WOULD LIKE TO ADVOCATE FOR
THAT TO CONTINUE AT SOME LEVEL
FOR FOLKS IN -- THE THE THE
OTHER THING IS JUST IF WE COULD
BRING BACK SOME FUNDING FOR
CAMPS AND RECREATIONAL PROGRAMS
BECAUSE OUR POPULATION IS NOT
HAVING.
A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY TO
SOCIALIZE.
RIGHT IT WITH HIM OTHER THAN
MAYBE WITHIN A VERY SMALL FAMILY
GROUPS OR WORK GROUP AND LITTLE
AMOUNTS CAN MAKE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
.
HELLO MY NAME IS SONORA PARKER
AND I SEVEN PEOPLE'S FIRST AS A
SECRETARY WITH THE MARSHAL'S.
OFFICE AND I WOULD LIKE IT IS
CASACORNELIA MEDIUM ILIFE.
THEN I'M A PART OF HER HIGH --
LET'S SEE AGENCY.
WHICH IS CALLED LIVING PURPOSE.
ALL THE BOOKS REGIONAL PLEASE.
YOU THE CONTINGENT.
I WORKERS THREE MONTHS.
BECAUSE THERE'S NOBODY.
SO I HAVE ON THE BOOKS.
EVERY JOKE AND PAY FOR AYE OVER
SERVICES.
WHAT IBM?
BUT THE ONLY PERSON I GET IS THE
OWNER.
IS THE LET YOU KNOW THAT THEY
NEED.
TO INCREASE YOU CAN'T JUST HAVE
SERVICES ON THE BOOKS.
NEVER REACH THE PEOPLE.
BECAUSE I'M ONE OF BECAUSE OUR
PROGRAM YOU ACTUALLY HAVE TO DO
ONE OF THE AYE.
COOL GET PAID FOR DOING.
I'M BEEN WAITING FOR ONE MONTH.
THE DESTRUCTION OF CLEANING DOWN
OR STEP.
HI HI MY NAME IS TERRA BILO I'M
ATTACHING SPECIALIST FOR ACT
INDEPENDENT LIVING SUPPORTED
LIVING AND RESPITE SERVICES.
AND I HAVE A QUICK COMMENT TO
MAKE ON BUT MR HER SHE AND MR
CENTERS OF BEFORE -- TWENTY SOME
YEARS AGO I WAS A GROUP HOME
COORDINATOR -- FOR AN ARC GROUP
HOME.
AND WE HAD FOR ABOUT A YEAR.
A SOLID STAFF BASS SAME PEOPLE
EVERY SHIFT EVERY DAY.
AND THE PROGRESS WE SAW WITH THE
PEOPLE LIVE I MEAN THAT'S THEIR
HOME AND TO HOW STRANGERS COMING
IN AND OUT EVERY DAY YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO SEE PROGRESS AND THE
THINGS THAT THEY NEED TO LEARN
AND DO.
WHEN WE HAVE THAT STABLE STAFF
THERE?
PEOPLE CAME OUT OF THERE SO WE
WOULD SIT IN THE LIVING ROOM TO
WATCH TV IT FELT LIKE A HOME.
AND SO THAT SO SORELY NEEDED
THESE DAYS THE TURNOVER IS
RIDICULOUS -- AS A PARENT A
SPECIALIST ONE OF THE THINGS I
WANTED TO TOUCH ON KIND OF GOES
TO THE GROUP WOMAN HOUSING
CRISIS WE HAVE BUT I HAVE A LOT
OF PARENTS PROBABLY MOSTLY
SINGLE PARENTS THAT -- HAVE.
IDC BUT ALSO HAVE CHILDREN IN
THE HOME.
AND SOME OF THE CHILDREN HAVE
DISABILITIES AND SOME DON'T AND
SO WE GO IN THE HOME WANTING TO
MAKE SURE THE CHILDREN ARE ON
TRACK DEVELOPMENTALLY AND HAVE
WHAT THEY NEED BUT A LOT OF
TIMES.
IF THE PARENTS DON'T HAVE
FUNDING FOR HOUSING OR HAVE A
PLACE TO GO THERE'S NO GROUP
HOME THAT WILL IT TAKE SINGLE
PARENTS AND CHILDREN WHERE WE
CAN GO AND WORK WITH.
OUR HAVE SUPPORTED LIVING FOR
THEM SO THAT'S A BIG CRISIS
WHERE THEY KIND OF FALL THROUGH
THE CRACKS AS FAR AS WHERE WE
CAN GET THEM HOUSING BECAUSE
HERE ESPECIALLY IF YOU.
DON'T HAVE SSI OR IF YOU DON'T
HAVE.
YOU DON'T MAKE THREE TIMES IN A
MONTH WHAT YOUR RENT WOULD BE
NOBODY WILL GIVE YOU AN APART
SAID SO THERE HAVE A PLACE TO
LIVE IN A LOT OF THEM ARE ON THE
STREETS.
FOR IMMINENTLY GOING TO BE THERE.
BUT THEY NEED SERVICES IN A
PLACE. TO LIVE WITH THEIR
CHILDREN.
WHERE THEY CAN SERVICE
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS STACY EMERSON AND
I HAVE A DAUGHTER WHO HAS --
INTELLECTUAL.
DISABILITIES SHE WAS ADOPTED SHE
WAS EXPOSED PRIMARILY TO ALCOHOL
AND DRUGS.
AND SHE SUFFERED TRAUMA
[INAUDIBLE]
AND I AM I'M REALLY JEALOUS OF
SAN DIEGO'S REGIONAL.
I'LL TELL YOU THAT I AM BECAUSE
OURS IS NOT THAT GREAT -- I HEAR
A LOT OF PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT
HOW GROUP HOMES ARE UNDER FUNDED
AND REGIONAL CENTERS ARE VERY
EXPENSIVE.
AND I KNOW THAT THERE WILL
ALWAYS BE A NEED FOR THAT TO BUT
THERE ARE A LARGE ARM COMMUNITY
OF PEOPLE ESPECIALLY IN THE
DOCTOR ADOPTIVE AND FOSTER CARE
COMMUNITY.
THAT DON'T BELONG IN THOSE IF
THEY WOULD JUST GET THE PROPER
TREATMENT EARLY ON AND THEY'RE
NOT GETTING BACK.
ON MY DAUGHTER IS ONE OF THOSE
KIDS THOSE FALLING THROUGH THE
CRACKS SHE HAS.
VERY EXPLOSIVE AND DANGEROUS
BEHAVIOR I'D GO TO MENTAL HEALTH
THE TIME WE GOT TO THE REGIONAL
CENTER I GO TO THE REGIONAL
CENTER THEY PROVIDE AB.
EIGHT ABA DOES NOT HELP CHILDREN
WHO HAS SEVERELY DISTURBED
BEHAVIORS YOU JUST DON'T.
SO I MUST NOT KNOWING WHERE TO
GO SHE HAS BEEN IN A GROUP HOME.
I'VE TAKEN ROUTE EVERY PROGRESS
THAT I HAVE NEED FOR HER HAS
BEEN ON MY OWN MY OWN RESEARCH
MY OWN.
THINKING OF MY OWN MONEY MY OWN
TIME I HAVE NOT RECEIVED ANY
HELP FROM THE REGIONAL CENTER
EXCEPT A LITTLE BIT OF RESPITE.
WHICH IS NOT ENOUGH IN ADDITION
TO THAT THE REST OF IT IS MY
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROVIDE IT TO
FIND A PROVIDER WHEN YOU HAVE A
CHILD THAT ME TO TALK TO
SOMEBODY.
AND THEY'RE GETTING PAID A
LITTLE TINY BIT OF MONEY YOU
CAN'T REALLY FIND SOMEBODY. TO
DO THAT YEAH I CANNOT FIND A
RESPITE PROVIDER I NEED SOMEBODY
TO HELP ME FIND THAT PERSON I
NEED THE REGIONAL CENTER TO DO
THAT.
IF MENTAL HEALTH COMMUNITY THE
COMMUNITY WILL NOT PROVIDE
SERVICES FOR MY DAUGHTER IN THE
SWITCH REGIONAL CENTER I NEED
YOU GUYS TO HELP ME FIND
PROVIDERS THAT WILL PROVIDE
SERVICES FOR HER.
BECAUSE OTHERWISE SHE'S GONNA
END UP IN A REGIONAL CENTER
SHE'S GONNA END UP COMING HOME
SHE I MEAN IN A TREATMENT CENTER
TO GIVE IN THE COMING HOME NOT
BETTER SHE'S GOING TO END UP IN
A GROUP HOME.
SHE MAY END UP HOMELESS AND ON
DRUG.
AND THOSE THAT'S A LARGE
POPULATION.
IN THE REGIONAL CENTER AND
THEY'RE NOT GETTING THE
TREATMENT THAT THEY NEED.
SO WE DO HAVE THE STAFF MEMBER
FROM DDS HERE TONIGHT ALSO.
WILL.
OKAY UP WITHOUT AND ALSO -- BUT
REGIONAL CERTAIN USING.
FRESNO COUNTY OKAY.
SO WE DIDN'T DO HEARING UP
FRESNO AT LAST YEAR BUT I DON'T
I WASN'T AWARE OF IT AND THAT'S
ANOTHER PROBLEM IS THAT I'VE
BEEN TOLD NUMEROUS TIMES.
ABOUT SERVICES THROUGH THE
SUPPORT GROUPS THAT I'M ON THAT
THE REGIONAL CENTER SHOULD BE
PROVIDING THAT THE REGIONAL FOR
HAS NEVER PROVIDED ME THEY
DIDN'T TELL ME ABOUT RESPITE.
THEY DIDN'T TELL ME ABOUT.
I MEAN MOST OF THE SERVICES THAT
I GET I HAVE HAD TO REQUEST FROM
MY OWN.
WE'LL WORK WITH YOU OKAY CAM
KßT -- MICHAEL'S MY WIFE BONTA
MULLIN.
AND WE HAVE A THREE SIX REAL
DAUGHTER.
THAT -- IS THE JOY OF OUR LIVES
AND A LOT OF THE CHILDREN THAT.
OTHER PEOPLE DESCRIBE
[INAUDIBLE]
THERE IMPROVE.
THE SAME GENE POOL I THINK --
SHE'S WONDERFUL.
AND SHE'S BEEN LIVING AND A
GROUP HOLD DOWN YOUR HOMES IN
SPRING VALLEY.
OFFER LAST FIVE YEARS IN THE
FIVE YEARS SHE'S AWESOME.
AND I CANNOT.
PRAISE THEM ENOUGH FOR WHAT
THEY'VE DONE.
BUT THEY ARE STRUGGLING TO KEEP.
A CONSISTENT.
OUR STAFF TOGETHER.
AND I TOTALLY AGREE WITH THE
PRESENTERS TO LIVE.
WITH THE PROVIDERS.
THAT IS THE MOST CRUCIAL THING
[INAUDIBLE]
IN.
IN THEIR LIVES ARE.
NOBODY CAN REALLY.
TALK FOR THEM OR THEY CAN'T TALK
FOR THEMSELVES A LOT OF THEM.
HERE.
EXPRESS THEIR NEEDS AND DESIRES
AND TO GET A NEW PERSON.
ALL THE TIME IT'S JUST LIKE
STARTING ALL OVER AGAIN LIKE
GOING INTO THE CLASSROOM YOU GOT
A NEW TEACHER.
OR WORSE YET A SUBSTITUTE
TEACHER.
AND SO [INAUDIBLE]
I JUST.
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
WHOLEHEARTED AGREEMENT.
THAT [INAUDIBLE]
MONIES.
IF IT'S NOT ON THE SHORT LIST OF
BUDGET ITEMS IT SHOULD BE IT
SHOULD BE AT THE TOP OF THEIR
SHORTLIST. TO PROVIDE MONEY SO
THAT THESE AGENCIES CAN PROVIDE
QUALITY GOOD HEALTH.
AND HAVE A STABILITY WITHIN
THEIR STAFF. TO PROVIDE THE TYPE
OF CARE THAT THEY'RE DEDICATED
TO PROVIDE.
AND WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BLOSSOMING [INAUDIBLE]
NO IDEA.
WE BOTH SAID THE SAN DIEGANS AND
WE HAVE OUR DAUGHTER WAS FROM
BIRTH I MEAN.
AND SO WE'VE GONE THROUGH THE
SWEET WATER SCHOOL DISTRICT.
ALL OF PRINTING TRANSITION
EVERYTHING AND THEN SHE GOT TO
BE TWENTY ONE TRANSITION WAS
OVER.
NADA.
NOTHING.
OCTOBER.
I'M SO LIKELY SHE HAD US.
AND SO BUT THEN WE STARTED
GETTING OLDER.
AND THE TWO THIRDS SPENDING MORE
TIME IN HER ROOM JUST.
READING MAGAZINES OR DOING
WHATEVER AND HE STARTED GETTING
WAY AND WE WILL AND WE DIDN'T
WANT TO BURDEN OUR OUR OLDER SON
WITH THINK IF YOU HAVE A WIFE
AND CHILD SO THING.
THOSE ARE LOOKING TO START
LOOKING IT TOOK SEVERAL YEARS.
OF TO START LOOKING AND AND THEN --
READ.
THROUGH A FRIEND WE'VE WE'VE
HEARD ABOUT NO HOMES AND IT WAS
A TWO YEAR WAITING LIST.
WE PUT OUR NAME ON IT AND ALL OF
A SUDDEN.
SB BUT I BELIEVE THE LORD ALONE
PROVIDE.
IN THE LOWER PROVIDED THIS THING
AND NOW AND SHIA.
SHE LOVES HER ROOM SHE HAS HER
OWN ROOM.
BUT THE THING IS SHE HAVE SHE
WORKS AT THE ARGUE YOU'LL CALL
HOLD.
SHE LOVES WORKING WITH KATHLEEN
SO SHE'S WORKING WITH THAT IN
THE MALL AND HE SHE'S TALKING
YESTERDAY SHE GOT ME. TEN
MINUTES ON THE PHONE TELLING ME
WHEN SHE DOES THAT THEY THAT
THEY THAT NEVER HAPPENED AND THE
THING IS A SPORTS.
SHE THE SPORT IS KING A SWITCH
APART I MEAN.
BASKETBALL TEAM EVEN THOUGH A
BASKETBALL WAS UNTIL THE MIDDLE
OF A SUDDEN SHE'S THROWING SHE'S
REALLY FINISHING UP TO THE
INTERNET AND THEN IF YOU STILL.
DON'T DO SO WELL SHE TOOK.
AND WHILE SHE GETS LIKE THAT YES
WE SHOULD.
YEAH I HAVE SO MUCH MORE TO TELL
BUT SPORTS IN.
AND OF ARTS IN THINGS THAT MAY
NOT BE MENTIONED BEFORE BUT
THAT'S REALLY CRUCIAL BUT IT'S
WITH OUR LOW HI MY NAME IS JAMIE
SHACKLE FORD IN HERE TONIGHT
WITH THE YMCA CHILD CARE
RESOURCE SERVICE SPECIFICALLY
TEENS EMOTION.
WHICH IS A PROGRAM THAT SERVES
TWELVE TO TWENTY TWO YEAR OLDS
ON THEIR HIGH SCHOOL CAMPUS
CURRENTLY WE SERVE SEVENTY
STUDENTS AND WE UNFORTUNATELY
HAD TO CLOSE ONE OF OUR SITES IN
DECEMBER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
DUE.
TO FINANCIAL ON SUSTAINABILITY
BECAUSE OF PROGRAM COSTS IN
HIRING QUALITY STAFF AND NOT --
KIND OF FREE IN PERSON RATES.
AND SO LIKE I SAID OUR MINGLES
OUR SOCIALIZATION INDEPENDENCE
WAS STAFF FACILITATION.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT JUST BECAUSE
A SCHOOL DAY AND DOESN'T MEAN I
U. P. ENDS AND OUR STUDENTS
STILL NEED A SAFE PLACE TO GO
AFTER SCHOOL SAFE AND REACHING
PLACE.
AND DURING THE SUMMER AND SCHOOL
BREAKS WE ALSO PROVIDE A FULL
DAY PROGRAM AND WE GOT A
COMMUNITY.
AND ARM GOALS ARE STILL
SOCIALIZATION INDEPENDENCE WITH --
THE EMPHASIS ON COMMUNITY SO
NAVIGATING PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION --
OF COURSE HAVING SO MUCH FUN AND
THEN LEARNING HOW TO ORDER IN
THE COMMUNITY AND JUST BEING A
PART OF THEIR COMMUNITY SO --
WE'VE FACED A HIRING CRISIS
SIGNIFICANTLY BECAUSE OF THE
RATES THAT WE JUST CAN'T AFFORD
TO PAY AND AGAIN LIKE AT GOING
WITH EVERYONE SO I JUST LOVE.
THE RATES TO PROVIDE QUALITY
SERVICE [INAUDIBLE]
GET.
SURELY ELBURN COLIN UNION HAS
JONES.
WHAT'S YOUR NAME AGAIN SIR.
MARK.
WHICH WILL.
NINE WE LAST NAME [INAUDIBLE]
WHAT -- I WOULD I I MEAN THE
HOUSE WARMER FROM ALONE.
DELUSION WILL WAS NINE WILL BE
WILL RIGHT AS YOU RUN.
HE WILL DRAWS.
VIDEO NEWS JUNE AND LET'S GO
WITH CAN SENATORS IN CALIFORNIA
OR IF YOU ARE REPUBLICAN OR
DEMOCRAT.
I'M A DEMOCRAT.
SO MY COLLEAGUE -- I'M.
MODEL BLOG HERE IS.
MY LUCKY IF YOU.
ACTUALLY HAVE OFFICE RIGHT NOW.
AS HE RETIRED.
WHAT'S YOUR NAME.
HERE TO TELL TO WHAT.
MY NAME.
I REMEMBER YEAH.
NORMAL MIDDLE NAME. ZERO WE WILL.
WHAT?
WE LAST NAME.
SHE TO GIVE ME TO REMEMBER IT
[INAUDIBLE]
FIRST NAME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE CHARLIE AND AND YOUR
FANTASTIC PERSON.
GOOD EVENING I THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO COME HERE AND
HERE IS OUT -- AND THANK YOU FOR
THE APRIL EIGHT POINT 2%
INCREASE -- MY NAME'S DAVID
THREESOME ALSO WITH THE YMCA --
THE DEPARTMENT HEAD FOR RESPITE
AND TEAMS IN MOTION -- HERE WITH
JAMIE WHO IS ALSO FROM YMCA OF
COURSE -- ARE A RESPITE SERVICES
ARE REALLY GONNA TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE EIGHT POINT 2% IT WILL
REALLY HELP THE FAMILIES AND
REALLY UP THE PROVIDERS SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT.
BUT IT DOESN'T TOUCH THE TEAMS
IN MOTION PROGRAM.
AND AS JAMIE STATED IT'S FOR
STUDENTS FROM.
TWELVE TO TWENTY TWO AND WE'VE
HAD.
A REALLY BAD HIRING CRISIS FOR
THE YEARS THAT WE'VE BEEN LUCKY
THIS YEAR WERE WERE FULLY
STAFFED THIS YEAR BUT WE'RE
CROSSING OUR FINGERS.
BECAUSE THE STAFF IS REALLY
COMMITTED TO THE STUDENTS
INDEPENDENCE AND THE HAPPEN GO
ON INTO INTO MORE ADVANCED
ADVANCED PROGRAMS.
TO ENHANCE THEIR INDEPENDENCE --
BUT WE DON'T KNOW HOW LONG
THEY'RE GONNA STAY BECAUSE OF
THE RATES IN THE RE SEVEN
CHANGED FOR YEARS.
AND WE'RE ALSO LOOKING INTO
TAYLOR DAY AND WE SURVEYED A LOT
OF OUR FAMILIES WHO.
HAVE THE STUDENTS WITH TEENS IN
MOTION AND 90% OF THEM ARE
REALLY INTERESTED IN THE TAYLOR
DAY SERVICE BUT IT'S ONLY.
THIRTY TWO HOURS A MONTH.
THOSE FAMILIES AND IT IS A
TESTAMENT TO THE PROGRESS OF OUR
STUDENTS BECAUSE REALLY ONE OF
THE HAVE BACK TO NORMAL SERVICE.
SO IF YOU COULD KEEP IN MIND THE
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND OF
COURSE WITH THE YMCA SO COURSE
WE HAVE.
IT'S OUR MIDDLE NAME AND TEENS
EMOTION WAS OF GREAT SUMMER CAMP.
AND TO KEEP THAT GOING -- JUST
PLEASE KEEP IN MIND THAT THE
INCREASES THAT YOU GUYS ARE
FIGHTING.
FOR REMEMBER REMEMBER THE AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS A MEMBER THE CAP
SPACE.
JUST TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT
SOCIAL WRECKING CAMP WAS A LINE
ITEM IN THE BUDGET TO BE
REINSTATED THIS YEAR.
AND A GUY REMOVED BUT THERE WILL
NOT BE.
IT'S NOT GOTTEN IT WILL JUST
KEEP PUTTING IN AND THERE TO DO
THAT I ALSO HAD A BILL.
THAT WOULD HAVE ACTUALLY
EXTENDED SUMMER SCHOOL FOR THE
ID POPULATION SO IT WENT THERE
WAS NO GAP.
THAT ALSO GONNA REMOVE.
SO.
WE UNDERSTAND WE'RE GOING TO
WORK ON ON THE PROCESS BECAUSE
WE UNDERSTAND THE VALUES
SOCIALIZATION [INAUDIBLE]
THANK.
HI.
MY NAME IS JULIE AUSTIN I AM ON
THE STATE COUNCIL FOR
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES THIS
YEAR AGAIN.
AND I ALSO -- CHAIR THE
LEGISLATIVE AND PUBLIC POLICY
COMMITTEE FOR THE STATE COUNCIL
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
OR BASS I AM YOUR CONSTITUENTS
AND I MET YOU OUTSIDE OF THE
HOTEL IN MAY I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
REMEMBER ME.
I DO REMEMBER THAT.
SO IT'S NICE IS YOU IT'S REALLY
AWESOME THAT YOU'RE HERE -- MORE
IMPORTANTLY I AM THE MOTHER.
OF THREE CHILDREN AND MY
YOUNGEST IS TWENTY FOUR YEARS
OLD.
AND SHE HAS A DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY SHE'S HYDROCEPHALUS
TERRIBLE POLICY AND SEVERE
BEHAVIORAL ISSUES -- SO MY
QUESTION IS -- NOT ONLY FOR YOU
AS LEGISLATORS BUT ALSO FOR
CARLA.
CARLOS IS STILL HERE.
AND MY QUESTION IS ABOUT.
THE SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW BECAUSE
THE LOTTERY AND THE THE PEOPLE
THAT WERE CHOSEN TO BE PART OF
THE AT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
OF THE SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAM.
THAT WAS IN OCTOBER.
IS THAT CORRECT YEAH.
THAT HAPPENED IN OCTOBER YEAH.
AND SO.
HOWEVER THERE'S BEEN VERY LITTLE
PROGRESS AS FAR AS I CAN TELL ON
IMPLEMENTING THE PROGRAM AND I
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHO WOULD BE.
RESPONSIBLE OR ACCOUNTABLE. FOR
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT AND
WHAT IS THE TIMELINE.
SO WHAT WE'LL DO IS WE'LL HAVE
YOU TO WORK TOGETHER.
AND HILL REPORT OUT FOR YOU FOR
US OKAY.
SO THEY ARE MAKING THE WORLD SO
WE DO YOU CAN HAVE A PRIVATE
DISCUSSION WITH.
OKAY PERFECT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD EVENING.
HI MY NAME IS JOHN THE AND THIS
IS MY BOOK BECAUSE THE KNEES
SHE'S A SAVE THE SUPPORT ME --
I'M FROM THESE COUNTING AND I'M
IN THE BIG DREAM.
OF LIVING [INAUDIBLE]
SERVICE.
COACH THING SOME HANDS OF
WEAPONS AND THAT I BELIEVE.
THEY'RE STRONGLY -- IF YOU HAVE
A DISABILITY ANYONE OF WORK I
FEEL LIKE YOU CAN HAVE THE RIGHT
TO WORK EITHER FULL TIME OR PART
TIME AND NOT EFFECTIVE -- SOCIAL
SECURITY.
MY NAME'S DENISE BALANCE I'M
WOULD DREAM BIG INDEPENDENT
LIVING SERVICES.
AND SHAUNA HAS RUN INTO SOME
ISSUES WHERE SHE WORKS AND SHE
MAKES OVER THE THOUSAND SEVENTY
TWO DOLLARS AND JUST BECAUSE YOU
MAKE OVER A THOUSAND SEVENTY TWO
DOLLARS.
AND A SIX MONTHS PERIOD WITHIN A
FIVE YEAR PERIOD YOU NO LONGER
DISABLED.
THEREFORE THEN HER SERVICES OR
HER SSI GETS CUT THEN SHE
DOESN'T WANT TO WORK SO I
BELIEVE A LOT OF THE PROBLEMS
POSSIBLY FOR WORK.
IS THAT IF THEY WORK. THREE CAN
GETS CUT TOO MUCH THEN THEY
CAN'T LIVE SO IF WE COULD COME
UP WITH A SOLUTION POSSIBLY.
TO RAISE THE RATE WHICH THEY CAN
MAKE MORE MONEY SO THEY DON'T
GET CUT.
THEN I THINK THAT WE WOULD SEE
MORE EMPLOYMENT HAPPENING AND
THAT THEY WOULD -- STANDARD JOBS
LONGER ALSO I JUST ALSO WANT TO
SAY I DO AGREE WITH EVERYBODY
ELSE AS FAR AS LIKE WE NEED MORE
WORK WAGE INCREASE BECAUSE
JUSTICE THE DOM BRING.
KNOWLEDGEABLE AND SKILLED
EMPLOYEES TO THE FIELD AND
RETAIN THEM IT'S I'VE BEEN IN
THE FIELD NOW 425- YEARS I
STARTED OVER AT HOME A GUIDING
HAND.
I WENT BACK TO COLLEGE AND THEN
I TURN AROUND WORKED AT ARC AND
THEN I JUST OPEN MY OWN AGENCY
AND SO I AM SEEING THE STRUGGLES
NOW THAT ARE WITH THE RATE BUT I
AM A PASSION ABOUT WHAT I DO AND
I LOVE WHAT I DO AND I'M.
NOT IN THIS FOR THE MONEY I
DON'T THINK ANY OF US THAT ARE
IN THIS ROOM DO THIS FOR THE
MONEY.
AS IF WE DID.
IT'S NOT THE MONEY THAT KEEPS US
HERE IS OUR PASSION FOR OUR
CONSUMERS OUR CLIENTS WE WANT TO
SEE THEM SUCCEED.
SHE HAS HAD SO MANY ISSUES
TRYING TO GET A JOB AND SUSTAIN
A JOB -- JUST BECAUSE OF
FLUCTUATION WITH DIFFERENT
EMPLOYEES AND OUR WITH DIFFERENT --
AGENCIES AND HAVING.
PROBLEMS COME IN BETWEEN HER AND
THE WORKERS AND SO I THINK WITH
THE CONSISTENT.
AGENTS ERA WHERE CONSISTENT
WORKER THAT CAN DO THAT AND I'M
WITH THE WEIGHT WAGE CAFFEINE
RACE THAT WOULD REALLY BE
HELPFUL FOR EMPLOYMENT FOR
CLIENTS.
THANK YOU CAN I ADD SOMETHING TO
THIS PLEASE -- I JOIN IS TO MOVE
OUT OF MY PANTS PLACE AND I NEED
THE MONEY FOR THAT SO THAT WAY I
CAN GET AN APPOINTMENT.
WORKING ON THAT.
LEAVE ME THAT WAS MY DREAM WHEN
I WAS YOUNG I WISH I WAS BACK MY
PARENTS [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
THIS MORNING.
I HAVE A DAUGHTER WHO JUST
TURNED THIRTY FIVE WHO IS A LOT
DIFFERENT THAN MOST OF THE OTHER.
PRESENTERS AND PEOPLE TALK
YOU'RE MY DAUGHTER DOESN'T WANT
DOESN'T TALK THIS NEW CHIU WEARS
DIAPERS.
AS PHYSICAL ISSUES AND HAS.
DIETARY ISSUES.
WE NEVER FOUND A DAY PROGRAM
THAT IT COULD MEET HER NEEDS
WE'VE JUST.
BEEN WE'VE BEEN PART OF THE SELF
DETERMINATION PARTY HERE IN SAN
DIEGO SHE'S PART OF A PILOT.
AND WE DROPPED OUT BECAUSE AFTER
GOING TO THE TRAINING SESSION.
I ALREADY HAVE A TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN JOB I DON'T NEED TO ADD
HIRING.
FINING PEOPLE TRAINING PEOPLE.
AND AS THE GENTLEMAN FROM YOU
SEE HE SAID IT'S HARD TO KEEP
GOOD PEOPLE.
LOSING PEOPLE TRAINING PEOPLE WE
ALREADY DID -- SELF DIRECTED
SERVICES.
AND I WAS CONSTANTLY TRAINING
PEOPLE AND HAVING THEM IN MY
HOUSE IF WE GO OUT INTO THE
COMMUNITY.
WHERE THE TEEN WHO DIED?
THERE'S NO PLACE.
AND WE TRAVEL.
NEW ZEALAND'S BEEN THE ONLY
PLACE WHERE WE'VE ACTUALLY FOUND
ACCESSIBLE BATHROOMS EVERYWHERE
WE GO WITH IS ACTUALLY PLACE TO
LIVE SOMEBODY DOWN TO CHANGE A
DIAPER.
THIS COUNTRY THE CITY NOT GOING
TO HAPPEN.
SO THAT'S A BIG ISSUE AND FOR US
WITH SELF DETERMINATION IT IS
MOVING FORWARD.
AND I THINK THAT WAS ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS A COUPLE PEOPLE ABOUT
IT'S GOING I'M JUST NOT SURE FOR
US WITH.
WITH PEOPLE WITH REALLY
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES.
IT'S GOING TO BE A GOOD FIT.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
SAID IT WOULD BE GREAT FOR
PEOPLE WITH SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES WITH FAMILY MEMBERS
TO BE ABLE TO TALK TO EACH OTHER
TO SAY.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO TO PULL YOUR
SERVICES BECAUSE OF I'VE GOT A
PERSON WHO CAN GO OUT GO BOWLING
THAT'S ONE THING? FIVE WE HAVE A
PERSON CAN'T PHYSICALLY DO
ANYTHING.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO BE A FIT BUT
MAYBE BY.
SHARING IDEAS MAYBE WE CAN GET
SELF DETERMINATION TO WORK FOR A
PHYSICAL.
WE CHALLENGED INDIVIDUALS.
THE OTHER AT THE HEAD AND BE
REAL QUICK AS I WAS ABOUT
DIAPERS.
LORENA GONZALEZ JUST GOT
SOMETHING PASSED WITH THEIR
TAKING TAX NOT CHARGING TAXES OR
DIAPERS AND SANITARY PRIDE.
PRODUCTS FOR WOMEN.
YOU HAVE A POPULATION OF PEOPLE
WHO WE'RE INCONTINENCE SUPPLIES
SAFE FROM THE AGE OF SIX TO
EIGHTEEN WHO MAY NOT GET
[INAUDIBLE]
MEDIC OUT.
YOU HAVE TO PAY TAXES ON I GREW
UP MASSACHUSETTS THERE'S NO
SALES TAX ON INCONTINENCE
SUPPLIES FOR CHILDREN.
OR ADULTS SO MY REQUEST WOULD BE
IS PERHAPS TO CONSIDER.
IF WE'RE NOT CHARGING SALES TAX.
FOR THAT PARTICULAR GROUP IT GOT
PASSED BY MS GONZALEZ THIS BILL
MAYBE WE SHOULD CONSIDER THAT
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT DISABLED
POPULATION AS WELL AS WELL.
WE ACTUALLY BY OUR DIAPERS NOT
THROUGH MEDICARE HEALTH BECAUSE
THEY DON'T CARRY THE BRAND THAT
WORKS WELL FOR A DAUGHTER.
WE PAY TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE
DOLLARS EVERY. FIVE WEEKS TO
DIVERT.
THAT'S A LOT OF TAXES.
IT'S A LOT OF MONEY AND SO IF
YOU TAKE A THOUSAND DOLLARS OR
NINE HUNDRED DOLLARS IN SOCIAL
SECURITY.
IF YOU HAD TO TAKE THAT OUT AND
IF SHE'S LIVING IN AN APARTMENT
[INAUDIBLE]
WHAT WHO?
WHAT FOOD SERVICES WHAT ANYTHING
ELSE?
SO MY REQUEST WOULD BE TO PULL
THIS ONE TWO SEATER THIS.
VERY SMALL POPULATION IN PUBLIC
SCHOOL IT WAS 1%.
IS ALSO THE FACT THAT ONCE YOU
GET OUT OF PUBLIC SCHOOL NOT A
WHOLE LOT OUT THERE. FOR
RESOURCES THERE FOR SUPPORT SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
THANK YOU FOR COMING DOWN
[INAUDIBLE]
LEAVING.
GOOD EVENING THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
MY NAME IS JACQUELINE HOW THOMAS.
I HAVE A THIRTY NINE YEAR OLD
SON WHO IS -- HE'S HIGH
FUNCTIONING BOOK COGNITIVE THE A
THREE YEAR OLD.
AND HE WORKS WITH THE JOB COACH.
I THINK THAT WE DO NEED FUNDING
FOR ALL OF THESE AREAS FOR
EMPLOYMENT.
EDUCATION HOUSING -- HE RECENTLY
CAME UP ON THE SECTION EIGHT
LIST WHICH I PUT HIM ON WHEN HE
TURNED EIGHTEEN IT TOOK US
FIFTEEN YEARS. TO GET THERE.
AND WE WERE DOWN.
TO ABOUT A WEEK WEEK AND A HALF
OF LOSING THE VOUCHER BECAUSE WE
CAN FIND ANYTHING.
IN ALL PLACES THAT WERE
AVAILABLE WERE NOT ACCEPTING
SECTION.
EIGHT YOU KNOW AND I FOUND OUT
THAT.
HAVE WE LOST THE VOUCHER THERE'S
NO APPEAL RECOURSE I WOULD HAVE
GONE BACK OWN LIST.
YEAH MY CONCERN IS WHAT HAPPENS
TO MY CHILD WHEN I'M NOT HERE I
DON'T HAVE A WHOLE LOT OF FAT
LADY. TO DEPEND ON THE MAKE SURE
HE'S TAKING CARE OF I AM VERY
GRATEFUL. TO REGIONAL CENTER
WHICH HE HAS BEEN WITH OVER
THIRTY YEARS.
THEY HAVE PROVIDED A LOT OF
RESOURCE.
BUT A LOT OF FUNDING HAS BEEN
CUT.
AND THE FUNDING IS NEEDED -- HE
IS LIVING INDEPENDENTLY WITH --
ROOMMATE.
AND THAT FUNDING IS LIMITED
WE'RE ON A SCHEDULE WHERE I
STILL HAVEN'T MET MY HOUSE THREE
DAYS A WEEK.
I WON HIM TOTALLY DEPENDENT FROM
ME BECAUSE AS MUCH AS I'D LIKE
TO LIVE FOREVER I WANT.
SO -- THE FUNDING IS GREATLY
NEEDED IN ALL AREAS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
THANK.
MY NAME IS LEE YOUNG AND ROOMS
AND I'M HERE FROM FRESNO COUNTY
AND MY SON AS DEVELOPMENTAL
DELAYS AND NO MORE.
HE HAS OF FETAL ALCOHOL SYNDROME.
THE DOCTOR [INAUDIBLE] SEVENTEEN
MONTHS.
AND MY THE CNC OF REGIONAL
CENTER FIND THAT TIME.
WHEN HE TURNED THREE THEY
DECIDED HE DIDN'T [INAUDIBLE]
AND WE HAD A REALLY HARD TIME
GETTING HIM BACK IN BECAUSE THEY
THOUGHT ALL OF HIS PROBLEMS WERE
MENTALLY ON SO. FOR US AND
THEY'RE NOT PREPARED TO DEAL
WITH.
HE IS VERY DEVELOPMENT IN THE
LONG.
BUT THEY WANT TO GIVE US THINGS
TO BE A SERVICES.
WHEN HE NEEDS THEIR?
AND SEND A GROUP HOME AT THIS
TIME.
AND THEY CALL IT A THERAPEUTIC
GROUP KHÔNG BUT HE'S NOT
RECEIVING IN THERE.
YET EXCEPT FOR WHAT I'M PAYING
FOR OUT OF POCKET TAKING
[INAUDIBLE]
SO. FOR US WE WANT TO SEE.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
TALK MORE WITH YOU CAN ALSO
REALLY HAD A HARD TIME AND THANK
YOU.
A FEW MORE MINUTES IF THERE'S
ANYBODY ELSE WOULD LIKE TO SHARE.
EXPERIENCE OUR CONCERNS OR MONA
[INAUDIBLE]
NOW THERE'S I START STEP TOWARDS
OUR SECOND -- I STARTED A
SUPPORT GROUP UP IN RAMONA
BECAUSE WHEN I MOVED UP THERE
ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO I REALIZE
THAT WE WERE.
VERY FAR OUT THERE AND IT WAS
HARD TO GET LIKE BEHAVIORAL
SUPPORTS OF THEIR TRANSPORTATION
OUT THERE.
AND I'VE STARTED TO MEET A LOT
OF OTHER PARENTS AND I'M FINDING --
WELL MY SON MIGHT GET SOME
SERVICES I'M SEEING OTHER
PARENTS ARE BEING UNDERSERVED OR
THEIR SITUATIONS ARE SO.
DIFFERENT LIKE FOR EXAMPLE
TRANSPORTATION.
RIGHT THEY'RE HAVING A HARD TIME
GETTING THEIR CHILD WHO'S AN
ADULT NOW.
DOWNHILL BECAUSE THERE'S NOTHING
NOTHING ROOM ON IN THE DAY
PROGRAM FACILITY.
AND I GUESS THROUGH REGIONAL
CENTER THERE -- CAP AS TO HOW
MUCH THEY CAN PAY AND FENDER.
SO IT LIMITS WHAT'S AVAILABLE TO
THESE PARENTS.
SIGN SEEN THAT AND ALSO -- MY
SON'S EIGHTEEN WHAT I'M HEARING
THAT AT TWENTY TWO BE AWARE I
MEAN THEY KIND OF FALL OFF A
CLIFF OF SERVICES AND THERE'S
NOT A LOT OUT.
SAW -- THERE'S A LOT OF PARENTS
THAT WERE.
THEY DIDN'T GET THE BENEFIT OF A
LOT OF THE GOOD SERVICES THAT
ARE OUT THERE NOW WHEN YOUR KIDS
WERE IN SCHOOL SYSTEM SO I KIND
OF FELL THROUGH THE CRACKS.
AND NOW THEY'RE OVER TWENTY TWO
AND ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR ITS
FROM SUPPORTS.
SO THERE'S NOT POPULATION OUT
THERE THAT'S KIND OF THE NEXT.
SO I JUST WANTED TO BRING THAT
UP I'M NOT SURE IF.
I'M NOT AWARE OF THOSE SERVICES
I'D LOVE TO KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
SO I CAN KIND OF BRING THAT
INFORMATION BACK [INAUDIBLE]
CARLOS HERE.
HE SAID PRESIDENT COUNTY YOU CAN
ALSO.
AFTER THE FOR PREVIOUS WHEN I'M
SORRY.
IN A LONG DAY -- BUT CARLOS IS
HERE AND WE CAN PUT YOU TWO
TOGETHER AND THAT'S WHAT I LOVE
ABOUT THESE AS WE CONNECT THE
INDIVIDUAL'S RIGHT AWAY
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
OUR MONITOR MY HELLO
[INAUDIBLE]
ON I JUST WANT TO THANK.
ME -- MY NAME IS MELISSA BACK
THERE.
I JUST CAME INTO REGIONAL CENTER
[INAUDIBLE]
LAST [INAUDIBLE]
YEAR.
IN OCTOBER NOVEMBER [INAUDIBLE]
AND ON IT HELPED ME -- BUT MY
CONCERN IS [INAUDIBLE]
A LIGHT.
HOW?
A MAN LIKE LOW INCOME.
HOUSING A PROGRAM CALLED MODERN
WE HAD LIKE SECTION [INAUDIBLE]
EIGHT BUT LATE [INAUDIBLE]
I'M AFRAID.
LET MOM RENT JUST ONE ALL
[INAUDIBLE]
BUT I'M AFRAID GET LIKE IF I
HAVE THE MORAL.
AT CAMP RANDALL APARTMENT
BECAUSE THERE'S NO.
ABOUT TWO WICKS BY AND SOMETHING
THAT YOU NAY.
IN THE FINAL HANDLE BALL.
SO MY CONCERN IS HOUSING.
AND ON TO EACH TOWN REGIONAL
THANK.
SO I WON AN ALL.
OR DO I TALKED TO WHEN THAT TIME
COMES.
IN EACH COUNTY REGIONAL.
SO CLOSE AGAIN AS HERE WILL MAKE
SURE THE HAS AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO GET.
THAT'S OKAY BUT HE CAN GET YOU
CONNECTED WITH THE RIGHT PEOPLE
AND IN THE IN THE NETWORK.
BUT YOU CONCERNS OUR CONCERNS
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET
CONNECTED TO THE RIGHT PEOPLE
OKAY.
ALSO.
OKAY I'M ON SOCIAL SECURITY TO
NOT FOUND A JOB WITH GOOD WILL
AND JUST START.
WORKING.
BUT MY CONCERN IS [INAUDIBLE]
LAKE.
NEW YORK ONE IF YOU MAKE A
CERTAIN AMOUNT.
WITH A CUT YOU ALL IF YOU JUST
SAY.
AND WE'RE GONNA WORK ON THAT
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT OVER TIME
THE THOSE NUMBERS OF STATE
STAGNANT.
AND THE COST OF LIVING HAS
INCREASED BUT THE CAP HASN'T
INCREASED.
SO WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT WHAT
FEDERAL LAWS IN PLACE AND WHAT
STATE ONCE AND WORK WITH OUR
ELECT IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE TRYING TO GET TO A LEVEL OF
OF OF BALANCE.
FORTY BECAUSE I WOULD MEAN WHEN
I'M ON SOCIAL SECURITY.
LIKE JUST THAT ALONG AT CAN'T
LIVE ALL.
NO NOW I'M DOING ALRIGHT WITH
Y'ALL.
WE HEAR YOU [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DANNY MY DON'T AND
MICE STORY IS [INAUDIBLE]
I'M CLUMSY.
MY STORY IS ON MY SAND WAS IN
THE SPECIAL NEEDS CLASS SCHOOL
OVER IN LA GUARDIA.
AND THEIR GOAL WAS JUST TO GIVE
THE DIPLOMA.
SO HE GETS HIS DIPLOMA AND WE
THOUGHT IS PARENTS THAT WHEN YOU
GOT THAT DIPLOMA.
THE WORLD WAS GONNA OPEN UP.
IN AUGUST JOHN FAST FOOD JOBS
JOB AFTER JOB AFTER JOB.
NOW WE DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THE
REGIONAL CENTER AND SO AS
PARENTS.
I WAS THE ONE WHO TOOK CARE OF
EVERYTHING HIS FATHER WAS
MILITARY AND GONE SO I DIDN'T
HAVE THAT SUPPORT.
SO FAST FORWARD HAVE AND HE'S
NOW.
FORTY SEVEN TOOK. TEN AND A HALF
YEARS TO GET THE REGIONAL CENTER.
I HAVE IT ALL WELL DOCUMENTED.
WHAT HAPPENED I ASSUME AT THE
REGIONAL CENTER?
I UNDERSTAND IT'S GOTTEN BETTER
AND I APPLAUD THEM IN I APPLAUD
ALL THIS AUDIENCE WHO
[INAUDIBLE]
ARE SO -- CUENTA ABOUT THE
SERVICES THAT THEY HAVE GOTTEN.
IT'S WONDERFUL [INAUDIBLE]
HOWEVER.
I TOOK ELEVEN AND A HALF YEARS
FOR MY SON TO GET HOUSE.
WHERE DO WE GO FROM THAT?
I'M SEVENTY YEARS OLD SEVENTEEN
A HALF.
I'M THE ONLY CHILD HIS FATHER IS
DECEASED MY SON IS AN ONLY CHILD
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK GOODNESS.
YEAR AND A HALF AGO WE DID GET
THE REGIONAL CENTER.
IT WAS WONDERFUL BECAUSE THEY
HELPED US GET INTO AN AGENCY.
BLOSSOM IT'S A WONDERFUL AGENCY
AND HE HAS A SOCIAL WORKER.
SOCIAL WORKER COMES AND SHE
HELPS HIM WITH THEM HE'S NOT
HIGH FUNCTIONING.
HE IF YOU WERE IN THIS ROOM YOU
WOULD THINK HE'S A COLLEGE
GRADUATE.
GARY SIMS SELL SO WELL HE'S
BRILLIANT HOWEVER HE HAS THE
COGNITION WITH THEIR SKILLS OF
ABOUT.
A FIFTEEN OR SIXTEEN YEAR OLD.
SO MY PREVIOUS OUT OF ALL OF
THIS WE'VE DONE OUR STRUGGLES BE
PAID OUR TIME.
BEARING THE FACT THAT HE'S FORTY
SEVEN I'M SEVENTY THERE IS NO
FAMILY WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE.
MY DAILY JOB IS SPENT FOUR AND
FIVE HOURS A DAY.
HE'S AN INDEPENDENT HOUSING FOUR
TO FIVE HOURS OF MY DAY ARE
SPENT.
TAKING CARE OF BUSINESS CALLING
AGENCIES ARE FILLING OUT FORMS.
IT'S TIME THAT I SHOULD BE
SPENDING WITH.
MY AGE AND HAVING FUN AT NIGHT
HE'LL SAY WELL LET'S GO OUT TO
DINNER I'M TOO TIRED.
AND THAT'S GOING ON AND ON AND
ON SO I THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE
MORE.
I KNOW THE SERVICES ARE OUT
THERE BUT HOW DO WE FIND THEM
WHERE DO WE GO WHAT WEBSITE.
AND IT'S JUST SO LONG.
I FINALLY FOUND A GROUP A COUPLE
YEARS AGO AND IT'S CALLED --
IT'S IN FAR AND IT'S A ON A
GROUP OF WOMEN WHO GET TOGETHER
TO HAVE THESE -- CHILDREN.
THERE'S VERY FEW -- ADULTS MICE
AND I'M THE OLDEST WHEN THEY ARE
BUT THAT'S OKAY.
BUT OUR WILL IT'S A WONDERFUL
SUPPORT GROUP AND WE HAVE
DIFFERENT SPEAKERS BUT OUT OF
ALL OF THEM.
MOST OF WHAT I'M FINDING IS THAT
IT'S BEARD THE SERVICES ARE
GEARED FOR YOUNGER KIDS.
AND YOU KNOW TRANSITIONING IN
ALL I DIDN'T EVEN.
I KNOW WHAT IT MEANS BUT WE
DIDN'T HAVE THAT AVAILABILITY SO
HERE WE ARE AND WHERE WE GO
THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT THING.
JUST INFORMATION RIGHT NOW WE
TAKE CARE OF OUR KIDS THE BEST
WE CAN.
GIVE US INFORMATION WHERE TO GO
AND WHAT TO DO.
YOUR IMMUNE AGAIN.
THANK GOD CARLOS'S.
THE ANSWER ME JUST LEFT THE
BUILDING NOW.
AND AGAIN ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I HAVE TO SAY AND WOOD AND I
CONTINUE TO SAY IS.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE ALL THE
REGIONAL CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA --
IT WORKS RUDE ARMAND DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES AS THE FACILITATOR FOR
THE FAMILIES.
AND SO -- AND I SAID EARLIER
THERE'S A PLACE IN HEAVEN.
FOR ALL OF THESE FOLKS SAID
[INAUDIBLE]
ACTUALLY.
HANG IN THERE WITH US AND MAKE
SURE THAT.
THEY DO THE BEST I CAN.
GOING FORWARD SO LOOK FOR DO YOU
HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH A
CARLOS [INAUDIBLE]
COME UP.
YOU KNOW YOU'VE GOT THE THREE
MINUTES.
COME ON A CONSENT YEAH.
I WANT TO REFLECT ON WHAT THAT
HE JUST SAID BECAUSE I MET HER
AT THE END OUR I'VE GOT A KID
APPROACHING THIRTY GEN.
AND WITH THESE -- PLACES I GO.
TO I KEEP HEARING OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN FROM.
LITTLE BABIES ADULT.
YES THEY CAN'T FIND SERVICES AND
REGIONALISTS SO MUCH TURNOVER.
THEY'RE NOT THEY DON'T KNOW I'M
ABOUT TO LOSE MY CASE MANAGER OR
BEEN WITH I THINK SEVEN YEARS
BECAUSE ARE MOVING US. TO SAN
DIEGO.
FROM THESE COUNTY THAT'S WHAT WE
ACTUALLY HAVE.
AND HE RETURNED MY CALL.
AND WHEN I KEEP HEARING FROM
EVERYBODY IS.
THEY DON'T GET CALLS BACKS.
WEEKS DAYS MONTHS.
I'M REALLY SCARED THAT I'M ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT MANY THINGS THAT
I FIND THAT HE LEADS I HAVE TO
TRIP OVER THEM.
THAT CASE MANAGERS DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S OUT THERE TO GIVE THAT'S
A BIG PROBLEM CAN'T GET SERVICES
OF THE CASE MANAGER DOES NOT
KNOW.
THIS MEETING I JUST HAPPEN TO
TALK TO HIS MANAGER TWO DAYS AGO.
AND I SO I THINK THERE'S
SOMETHING GOING ON YOU GUYS NO I
DON'T THINK CYCLE BECAUSE I'LL
GET UP SURE ENOUGH BECAUSE YEAH
THIS IS IT.
SO I WANT TO KNOW.
WHY CASE MANAGERS CANNOT?
WE HAVE A CASELOAD THIS IS
EIGHTY NINE DAHLE ME.
WHICH IS OUTRAGEOUS BECAUSE LIKE
WHEN I STARTED WITH REGIONAL IT
WAS.
FORTY AND SIXTY EIGHTY NINE WHY
NOT START [INAUDIBLE]
AND WHY IS THAT.
THEY JUST CAN'T SHOOT OUT HER
TECHNOLOGY WE HAVE THERE'S THIS
BE HAPPENING.
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW WHEN I WENT TO
THE THING THAT SHE TALKED ABOUT
LAST NIGHT.
NOBODY KNEW ABOUT IT.
I TOLD HER ABOUT IT.
I TOLD A COUPLE OF PEOPLE I KNOW --
SOME OF THEM BUT AND HAS A CHILD
LIKE IN.
AND SHE WANT TO BE HERE BUT SHE
HAD A CAR SHE HAD TO GO.
TO SHE COULD HAVE REARRANGED
WHICH COULD BECAUSE IT'S SO LATE
NOTICE.
SHE DIDN'T KNOW EITHER FROM HER
CASE MANAGER.
KEEP HEARING THAT OVER AND OVER
AGAIN THAT THEY DON'T CALL THE
DON'T TELL YOU.
AND I ONCE HAD A CHAT WITH THE
CASE MANAGER AND I SAID WHY ARE
NUMBER UP NOTIFIED WHEN THINGS
ARE HAPPENING IN THE COMMUNITY
TO FOR PEOPLE.
AND THIS IS WHY DO NOTIFY PEOPLE
WHEN I THINK IT HAS SOMETHING TO
DO WITH THEM.
I HAVE NEVER BEEN NOTIFIED EVER
DIRECTLY.
AND I WANT TO KNOW SOME OF THE
SERVICES THAT THE PROPOSAL WE
HAVE.
WHERE WE'VE BEEN NOTIFIED
THERE'S NOTHING OUT THERE
THERE'S NO CALENDAR AND THERE'S
NO LIST OF?
THINGS THAT CAN HELP ESPECIALLY
IN BEHAVIOR.
AND I'VE BEEN -- I'VE HAD.
PROBLEMS AS MY PERSON NEEDED A
SUPPORT GOT IT AND THEN WHEN HE
NEEDED TO TAKE YEAH SO WHEN I
GIVE IT TO YOU AGAIN.
AND IT TOOK THE LAW. TO WRITE A
LETTER.
AND THEN HE GOT IT.
I FIND THAT A SHAME THAT THEY
DON'T BELIEVE ME.
THAT THIS PERSON NEEDED SUPPORT
UNTIL I GOT LEGAL [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
WHO I DO WANT TO THANK ALL OF
YOU?
FOR THE COURAGE OF COMING UP ON
PUBLIC AND SPEAKING. TO US AND
SHARING YOUR EXPERIENCES.
I ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY -- TO CLOSE OUT HER
ALMONDS -- MY TERRACE AWKWARDLY
FAR AWAY FROM THE TABLE AS YOU
CAN SEE -- I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE I'LL.
THANK YOU ALL FOR SHARING YOUR
STORIES AND I THINK THAT YOU'RE
HAVING A SELECT COMMITTEE IN SAN
DIEGO AND THE FOLKS FROM NORTH
AND EAST EAST COUNTY WHO CAME
DOWN TODAY.
THERE ARE THERE'S LOTS OF WORK
WE NEED.
AND I THINK WHAT I WOULD LIKE
YOU TO LEAVE WITH IS TO KNOW
THAT.
WE ARE WORKING AND AND SOMETIMES
IT MAY FEEL LIKE WE'RE INCHING.
SOMETIMES WE MAY BE GOING MAYBE
LIKE FORTY RATHER THAN INCHING
TOWARD SOLUTIONS BUT YOU HAVE
PEOPLE UP IN SACRAMENTO WHO OR
WHAT.
ARE YOUR PARTNERS.
WE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
HELP SERVE OUR COMMUNITIES AND
EVERYBODY IN OUR COMMUNITY.
AND I AM THANKFUL THAT YOU
SHARED SO MUCH TODAY THERE'S SO
MUCH I KNOW I NEED TO LEARN
ABOUT THE SPACE -- THAT I HAVE
YET TO LEARN SO I INVITE YOU TO
COME AND COME TO MY OFFICE
THAT'S HAVE MEETINGS OF CONTINUE
THIS JOURNEY LET'S TALK ABOUT
LEGISLATION AND WHAT WE NEED TO
DO.
AGAIN THINKS THE CHAIR HE'S.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER STANDS UP
EVERY DAY FOR YOU GUYS IN
SACRAMENTO.
IT'S A BLESSING THAT I GET TO
WORK WITH THIS WOMAN -- THERE'S
NOT A THE PASSION THAT SHE BRING
FORWARD IS REINVIGORATING I'VE
BEEN THERE ARE NOW GOING ON
SEVEN YEARS.
AND SO HE GETS TO BE A GRIND
SOMETIMES A WHEN YOU GET.
SOMEBODY WITH OUR PASSIONATE
CONTINUES IT AS YOU OF AGAIN
INVIGORATED US IN INSPIRED US.
THIS WOMAN HAS BEEN A BLESSING
IN THE CAPITAL ALSO.
I DO WANT TO THANK AND I CAN'T
SAY ENOUGH ABOUT THIS WOMAN
SHOULD THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
DEPARTMENT OF THE LITTLE
SERVICES NANCY PARCHMENT.
SHE IS ABSOLUTELY IN YOUR CORNER
SHE'S BEEN IN THIS INDUSTRY.
FOR MANY YEARS AND AS THE
DIRECTOR DDA.
SHE HI ASHLEY.
ALBEIT THERE ARE ROAD BLOCKS IT
SHE GETS FRUSTRATED WITH.
BUT SHE IS IN YOUR CORNER.
WE WERE COLLECTIVELY TOGETHER
SHE CENTER STAFF MEMBER TONIGHT
THE BEER A HERE.
YOUR CONCERNS AND YOUR AND YOUR
SUGGESTIONS AND HE GOES A LOT OF
THE SUGGESTIONS THAT CAME OUT OF
THESE HEARINGS ACTUALLY ENTERED
INTO THE BUDGET THIS YEAR.
SO WHICH IS PHENOMENAL.
US SO I CAN'T THANK HER FOR
ANOTHER FOUR HER WILLINGNESS.
HOW TO WORK WITH ME ALSO?
ALSO CHRISTIAN RIGHT WHO IS THE
DIRECTOR OF SPECIAL EDUCATION.
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
AS A OF ABSOLUTE ADVOCATE AND A
MOTHER OF A SPECIAL NEEDS CHILD
ALSO.
AND SO WHEN YOU LOOK ABOUT THE
OF LIFE EXPERIENCE COMPONENT.
OF THESE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE UP
THERE ADVOCATING ALSO IN THIS
CAPACITY BEGIN BUREAUCRACY
[INAUDIBLE]
IS HORRIBLE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
YOUR NEED A ONE WE EDUCATE THEM
TO A COMPONENT OF WHAT IT TAKES
TO ACTUALLY BE EFFECTIVE.
THE WHEELS START TURNING.
THE WHEELS REALLY DO START
TURNING.
SOMEONE REALLY THANK -- ALSO ARE
HIGH WITH THE TROLL WHO ENTER OR
SERGEANTS -- SPECIAL SERVICES
HERE TO PROTECT QUESTION MYSELF.
ALSO WANTED TO OUR TO OUR TECH.
OF FOLKS FROM SACRAMENTO -- WHO
CAME IN -- AND BECAME -- OF MADE
THIS A POSSIBILITY TO LIVE
STREAM AND MAKE SURE OTHER
PEOPLE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE.
IN THIS -- IN THIS FORM -- I
LOVE MEETING ALL OF YOU TONIGHT.
I WANT TO REMIND EVERYONE THE TO
COMPLETE ONLINE REGIONAL CENTER
SURVEY AND YOU THE LINK AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE AGENDA.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK OUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WHO WERE HERE
THIS EVENING I WILL.
I CAN'T GOSH ABOUT HER ANYMORE
YOU GUYS WOULD GET.
SICK BUT I WANT.
YOU KNOW I JUST.
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS
LIKE I CAME FROM THE WORLD I WAS
A GENERAL CONTRACTOR.
AND NOW I'M IN YOU KNOW I I BANG
NAILS ALL DAY LONG WITH A HAMMER.
NOW I BANG NAILS ALL DAY LONG
WITH MY FOREHEAD.
OKAY.
AND SO THIS IS WHAT WE COME UP
AGAINST.
AND BUT WE'RE MAKING PROGRESS WE
ARE MAKING PROGRESS.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS I'M REALLY
PLEASED ABOUT.
IS THE GOVERNOR HER US
[INAUDIBLE]
ERNEST.
AND HE WAS WILLING TO WORK
FORWARD.
HELLO ALL OF US.
AND I WAS A COMMITMENT HE MADE
TO ME.
THIS MORNING.
SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO HAVING
THOSE MEETINGS WITH HIS CHIEF OF
STAFF AND HIM. TO BE ABLE TO
EXPLAIN ON A MORE INTIMATE LEVEL
OF WHAT IS NECESSARY AND BECAUSE
YOU'VE TAKEN THE TIME TO TEACH
ME.
I'M NOT AN EXPERT.
WHEN YOU TEACH ME AND I AM ABLE?
TO LEARN FROM YOUR REAL LIFE
EXPERIENCE AND TO SHARE WITH THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE RELATIVE UP INTO
THE CAPITAL.
THAT'S WHEN WE CAN BE EFFECTIVE
TOGETHER.
YOU KNOW THE SUPPORT SYSTEM FOR
THOSE WITH DISABILITIES HAS
ANGERED FLUCTUATING LEVELS OF
SOME POOR FROM FROM THE STATE OF
THE PAST DECADE.
AND IT'S CRIMINAL IT REALLY IS.
YEAH.
THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS IDT
CONTINUES TO RISE DRAMATICALLY.
OVER THE LAST DAY DECADE AN
AVERAGE INCREASE RATE OF ABOUT
THREE POINT 7% ANNUALLY AS WE'VE
SEEN WITH YOUR INTEGRITY.
THE SCENE ABOUT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND NEW CONSUMERS INTO INTO
THE SYSTEM.
AND MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THIRTY IT.
DEPENDS ON WHO YOU TALK TO THREE
OF FIFTY THOUSAND ARE NOW BEING
SERVICE AND WE SHOULD EXPECT TO
SEE MORE.
WE'VE SEEN FEW GAMES IN OUR
STATE BUDGET TO MEET.
EVEN WHEN HE'S.
THE BUDGET WILL JUST PASSED DOES
INCLUDE A RATE INCREASE FOR
SERVICE PROVIDERS.
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THIS YEAR.
AND A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS NEXT YEAR.
THAT'S PHENOMENAL THAT HASN'T
HAPPENED IN DECADES SO THEY HAVE
BEEN HEARING YOU AS MY
COLLEAGUES MENTIONED.
OF THE INCHES MAYBE.
FOR IT ALSO INCLUDES ACCESS TO
STATE MINIMUM WAGE ADJUSTMENTS
BECAUSE IN THE RACE IDEA EARLY
IDENTIFIED THAT.
THERE WAS SOME CITIES THAT
ACTUALLY BUMPED THEIR MINIMUM
WAGE ABOVE STATE.
AND WE ARE GONNA TAKE CARE OF
THAT WHAT I CALL THE QUIRKINESS.
GOING.
FOR AND UNLIMITED THE STATE'S
NOT DOING NEARLY ENOUGH.
ADD COMMUNITIES BEING LEFT
BEHIND WHILE OTHER AREAS OF
SOCIAL SAFETY NETS ARE BEING
FULLY FUNDED [INAUDIBLE]
YOU MATTER.
YOU ABSOLUTELY DO MATTER.
INCREASE FUNDING FOR ADD POP
PROGRAMS THIS BUDGET PROVIDES.
OF THEY DON'T START UNTIL
JANUARY FIRST OF THE NEED IS NOW.
THE FACT IS THAT SOME PROGRAMS
CAN'T WAIT FOR THAT AND AS YOU
MEANT HEARD SOME PROGRAMS ARE
ACTUALLY GOING.
TO STOP TUNE BECAUSE THE
CALIFORNIA CONTINUE.
THIS BUDGET DOES LEAVE A LOT OF
PROGRAMS OUT AND THAT'S JUST
WRONG.
THESE PROGRAMS ARE STUCK
STRUGGLING BECAUSE OUR STATE HAS
LEGISLATORS GOVERNORS AND NOW.
THIS CURRENT LEGISLATURE.
I'VE ONLY MISSED HIM TO
INCREASES.
IN TWENTY YEARS.
THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION.
REJECTED GIVING INCREASED IS
SOME PROGRAMS EVEN.
THAT IT BELIEVES WILL BE OUT OF
FAVOR UNDER FEDERAL GUIDELINES
THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
IMPLEMENTED.
IN.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TODAY THESE
PROGRAMS ARE PROVIDING SERVICES
SELECTED.
OF BY PEOPLE WITH ADD AND THEIR
FAMILIES APPROVED BY REGIONAL
CENTERS -- IN THEIR AREA AND
MEET THEIR NEEDS IN YOUR
DISTRICT AND MY DISTRICT ALSO.
UNTIL WE HAVE A PLAN FOR OTHER
OPTIONS WE CAN'T SIMPLY ABANDON
THESE PROGRAMS ARREST THEM
FAILING BECAUSE WE THINK WE
MIGHT NOT RECEIVE FEDERAL
FUNDING. THREE YEARS FROM NOW
COME ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SENATE
MADE CHOICES TO FUND THE
PROGRAMS BASED UPON THE RATE
STUDY IT RELEASED IN MARCH.
BUT WE KNOW IT WASN'T JUST
ENTIRELY UP TO THE DDS I HAVE TO
TELL YOU THAT.
YEAH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
YOU HAVE THE ASSEMBLY OF THE
SENATE AND YOU HAVE.
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THAT ARE
WEIGHING IN ON THESE
[INAUDIBLE]
CRITICAL SERVICES.
BUT WE GOT TO KEEP IN MIND THAT
THE RATE STUDY.
IS NOT FINALIZED.
IT WAS IT WAS PROPOSED.
APARTMENT TOOK IN COMMENTS FROM
THE PUBLIC WHICH INCLUDED MANY
ADDRESSING HUGE FLAWS.
IN THIS STUDY.
AND SOME OF THOSE WERE THE RURAL
AREAS SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THAT THEY WERE ACTUALLY GONNA
LOSE MONEY DUE TO THE RATES.
TO THE DEPARTMENT HAS YET TO
ANSWER THESE COMMENTS BECAUSE
THERE WERE.
SEVERAL [INAUDIBLE]
GOING.
FOR BUT WE DO NEED THE ANSWERS.
AND IT'S OUR JOB PROVIDE THE
OVERSIGHT NECESSARY TO COMPEL
THEM TO ANSWER THESE QUESTIONS.
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
AND LASTLY THE REYES STUDY SAYS
WE ARE UNDER FUNDING THE SYSTEM
BY ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION.
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE GENERAL
FUND.
WE DE DO.
WE NEED TO DO MORE.
AND I KNOW EACH OF YOU WILL HELP
US GET THERE. ONE TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS.
AS A GROWN TREE'S LEAVES AND
JOHN.
WE WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE LINE
ITEMS IN THE BUDGET.
WE ONLY HAVE ABOUT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS OF THE DISCRETIONARY
SPENDING OUT OF TWO HUNDRED AND
TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS THAT WE
ALLOCATE.
AND THE GENERAL FUND BUDGET.
THREE BILLION DOLLARS HAS TO
FILL SO MANY OTHER GALS.
WE'RE GONNA NEED A REVENUE
SOURCE.
AND THAT'S GOING TO BE OUR JOB.
AS CAN BE OUR JOB TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT IS.
WHERE IT'S GOING TO COME FROM?
BECAUSE I DON'T SEE A
WILLINGNESS [INAUDIBLE]
RIGHT NOW.
A POLL FROM.
ROB PETER TO PAY PAUL.
ONLY.
FOUR SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO WORK
ON THAT DILIGENTLY THIS YEAR.
A BECAUSE I'M PROUD TO SAY THE
GOVERNOR WAS VERY RESPONSIVE IN
THE IDC THIS YEAR WITH THE
EARNED INCOME CREDIT.
I WILL. FIVE ONE SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS OF HELL.
THE WORKING POOR IN CALIFORNIA
[INAUDIBLE]
ARABLE. TO MY CASTING HIM IS.
WAS WORK ON THE ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS GOING FORWARD.
YOU GOT THAT DONE.
THIS IS NEXT.
SO WE'RE GONNA DO.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE THIS
EVENING.
I CAN'T THANK YOU ENOUGH FOR
YOUR INPUT.
WE ARE GOING TO CONNECT SEVERAL
YOU WITH THE APPROPRIATE PEOPLE --
BUT AS I MENTIONED MY COLLEAGUES
OPEN AND WILLING TO TALK TO YOU
IN YOUR IN YOUR CAPACITIES.
I WANT YOU TO TEACHER ALSO.
SHE WAS ON THE PTA.
SHE IS A LOT TO LEARN.
BUT SHE'S A AVID LEARNER AND ONE
OF THE BOOKS SHINING STARS IN
THE ASSEMBLY.
YOU VERY MUCH AND HAVE A SAFE
JOURNEY HOME TONIGHT.
AND WE'RE NOT.
THANK YOU